[Musique]
Dominique chelcher bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle Serview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter
succintement alors je suis un chef
d'entreprise qui a une double vie d'un
côté je suis patron propriétaire d'une
PME en Alsace qui est un supermarché un
magasin SuperU c'est au bord de la
frontière allemande c'est mon entreprise
depuis très longtemps je fais ce métier
depuis 25 ans et de l'autre côté je suis
le PDG de systemu donc notre coopérative
puisqu'on est une coopérative de
commerçants indépendant 1200 patrons
1700 magasins cette coopérative est
dirigée par les patr de magasin dont je
suis l'ultime représentant et donc j'ai
cette double vie mon magasin en fin de
semaine le vendredi et le samedi et du
lundi au jeudi je suis à à Paris à
ringis à notre siège pour gérer la
coopérative et c'est toute l'originalité
de notre système qui est que j'ai les
pieds sur le terrain et en même temps
après je dirige le 4è distributeur
français voilà en quelques mots merci
d'être venu on a décidé de vous faire
venir parce que pour nous les les super
marché sont toujours à la pointe de la
technologie du renseignement économique
de la perception de
terrain en plus vous vous avez toujours
cette connexion avec votre territoire on
en profite d'ailleurs vous avez parlé de
ringis on salue le directeur général de
avig grro et et d'ailleurs on l'embrasse
et donc désolé pour cette petite
parenthèse personnelle c'est de votre
faute on parlera de ringiss après
d'ailleurs sur comment s dimensionné les
gos comment ça se passe les protocoles
de sécurité on pass les meilleurs on
commence on va parler inflation on va
parler social on va parler intelligence
économique on va parler géopolitique on
va parler peut-être du gouvernement et
des capacités du gouvernement à
anticiper certaines choses la première
question que je vais vous poser c'est
comment vous sentez la période qu'on
traverse à l'heure actuelle en terme
d'inflation et des répercussions sur la
classe
moyenne ben c'est la question
essentielle en
fait mon sentiment et et mon analyse
c'est que c'est effectivement la classe
moyenne qui est la plus touchée par ce
qu'on vit maintenant depuis 2 ans et et
je le sais je dirais à chaud puisque
pendant les fêtes de fin d'année je je
suis pas venu à Paris je suis resté sur
le terrain dans mon magasin
comme d'une part il y a plein de clients
que je connais depuis très longtemps et
d'autre part comme mon com commence à me
voir un peu à la télé les gens
m'arrêtent et me disent ah et ils me
disent toujours ah il faudrait leur dire
ça il faudrait leur dire ça et donc j'ai
eu beaucoup de discussions pendant les
fêtes avec tout le monde des retraités
des actifs et ce et ce que je retiens
c'est que les gens sont fortement
impactés par cette inflation ils le
disent ils ont envie qu'on relaie leurs
difficultés au quotidien et pourquoi je
parle de la classe
moyenne excusez-moi de vous couper la
classe qui est autour des 2200 € par
mois c'est ça exactement c'est le
chiffre effectivement celui-là quand
nous nos magasins nos 1700 magasins sont
essentiellement en province à 50 % dans
des communes de moins de 5000 habitants
donc on connaît ces territoires là quand
vous êtes une famille vous avez deux
trois enfants vous habitez dans un
pavillon à la campagne vous avez deux
trois
voitures vous payez très cher l'essence
au quotidien pour aller faire vos
courses aller au travail emmener vos
enfants au lycée et cetera
vous avez un
budget alimentation important parce que
vous êtes une grande famille et ben
c'est ces gens-l qui qui sont dans ce
contexte là qui sont le plus frappés par
l'inflation parce que les postes de
dépenses contrainte le logement le
Carbur on vient de dire mais tous les
abonnements ont fortement augmenté votre
budget alimentation il est extrêmement
important donc vous prenez l'impact de
21 % d'inflation sur 2 ans en
alimentaire plein pot vous n'avez avz
pas forcément beaucoup d'aide ou de
d'aide de l'État quand vous êtes dans
cette catégorie là et donc ces gens-là
souffr effectivement tout
particulièrement et il souffr un peu
malgré tout en silence quoi parce que
évidemment là moi je le dis on en parle
et cetera mais c'est pas les gens qui se
manifestent le plus mais ils sont
extrêmement impactés par la situation
actuelle est-ce que c'est une colère
froide et vous qui êtes à la frontière
allemande est-ce que vous commencez à
voir les cultur allemand euh se
s'éclaircir la voix avec leur tracteur
pour demander des choses au
gouvernement alors oui je pense que
c'est une colère assez froide une colère
assez contenue pour l'instant je ne
perçois rien comme j'ai pu le percevoir
au moment des gilets jaunes de
l'émergence gilets jaunes on pose
souvent cette question est-ce que vous
sentz quelque chose non je ne sens rien
d'une mobilisation de quoi que ce soit
donc oui c'est une colère froide je suis
au bord de la frontière allemande
j'observe le ce qui se passe
effectivement en Allemagne donc très
concrètement les agriculteurs allemands
sont en train beaucoup de bloquer le
pays euh parce qu'ils sont pas d'accord
avec politique d'économie du
gouvernement allemand euh il y a eu des
impacts sur la région frontalière avec
des blocages de passage de frontières
mais ça n'a pas débordé ça n'a pas
débordé en Alsace par contre par contre
euh et ça je le vois par mon mon métier
aussi les agriculteurs sont très
préoccupés les agriculteurs français
sont très préoccupés actuellement ils
ont fait des mouvements ces derniers
temps euh iront-ils jusqu'à ce qui se
passe en Allemagne ça je peux pas vous
le je peux pas vous le dire j'ai pas de
signe dans ce sens pour l'instant mais
je sais qu'ils sont très préoccupé par
la situation économique il y a eu ce
mouvement vous l'avez peut-être vu ils
ont retourné les panneaux euh de village
de nom de ville en Alsace partout les
panneaux sont retournés mais j'étais en
Vendé l'autre jour il y avait des
panneaux retournés c'était leur signe de
colère en
disant on marche un peu à l'envers en ce
moment quoi vous prenez ça pour un signe
de colère ou vous prenez ça pour un
signe d'organisation et de diplomatie
euh de diplomatie ou c'est un peu les
deux c'est ça exprime un signe de colère
et et et ça a voulu montrer aux élus à à
beaucoup de monde queil y a des choses
qui ne vont pas dans le monde agricole
actuellement clairement il y a il y a le
sujet évidemment toujours du revenu qui
lui nous touche il a un lien avec nous
il y a le sujet des normes il y a le
sujet du renouvellement des générations
qui est très difficile dans dans dans
dans ce mondelà beaucoup d'agriculteurs
vont partir à la retraite et il y a des
difficultés à trouver la succession et
cetera ça les préoccupe énormément il y
a le sujet global de la souveraineté
alimentaire derrière tout ça ça c'est ça
c'est fondamental et il y a un sujet
aussi de mais nous nous travaillons au
quotidien et durement et parfois 7 jours
sur 7 pour nourrir les Français et nous
n'avons pas la reconnaissance qui va
avec nous n'avons pas le soutien nous
sommes parfois même visés et donc et
donc c'est tout ça qu'ils ont voulu
exprimer mais ils l'ont exprimé je
dirais pour l'instant et et quand je dis
c'est un peu diplomatique de dire on a
que tourné le panneau voilà c'est un peu
ça parce que on marche sur la tête voilà
ils ont voulu dire on marche sur la tête
et nous on connaît les agriculteurs
parfois il se manifestent d'avantage il
leur est déjà arrivé de venir sur le
parking de de certains de nos magasins
pour déposer un tas de fumierers pour
exprimer une colère particulière à un
moment précis et cetera mais voilà on n
est pas là pour l'instant on n est pas
au niveau de mobilisation de
l'Allemagne vous parlez de mobilisation
je vais je vais vous demander un
feedback sur deux trois choses euh les
émeutes qu'on a eu récemment en France
un peu partout dans certains quartiers
est-ce que vous avez été impactés est-ce
que certains de vos vos supermarchés ont
été touchés par des braquages des
véhicules béliers est-ce qu'il y a des
gens qui sont rentrés dans vos
supermarchés on a eu quelques intrusions
mais c'est resté à la marge sur un
réseau de 1700 magasins on a été
finalement peu concerné il y a eu
quelques intrusions il y a eu des
tentatives effectivement parce que un
moment et on l'a vu de manière plus
large il y a eu un peu d'opportunité
d'opportunisme à aller se saisir de
certains produits lesquels B c'était
c'était même beaucoup de produits en
fait alimentaires et on voyait bien
c'est un à ce moment-là ça faisait bien
le lien avec la situation actuel
d'inflation de difficulté de pouvoir
d'achat pour un certain nombre de
Français et moi ça m'avait frappé
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là que en marge
de ces émeutes certains produits qui
étaient volés c'était non plus ce qu'on
voyait par le passé c'est-à-dire plus du
non alimentaire et cetera mais c'était
même de quoi manger donc encore une fois
on a été peu touché on a pour tout dire
un magasin qui a été incendié et qui a
mis plusieurs mois à réouvrir et dont
les travonsx vont durer sous une forme
provisoire et qui va réouvrir dans
quelques temps mais après des travaux
donc un magasin donc non voilà on est on
est moins urbain on est plus rural et
dans les zones rurales bon c'était quand
même moins grave à ce moment-là on
continue sur le sujet avant d'aborder le
l'inflation plus en détail les questions
géopolitique et les les questions de
prospective on a une communauté qui est
relativement large d'ailleurs on les
embrasse tous et toutes et ils nous font
remonter en France et en Europe tout ce
qui est système antivol sur des steaks
hachés sur des plaquettes de beurre sur
des des antivols qu'on avait jamais vu
des espèces de petites grilles pour les
steaks des des des des choses comme
ça ça témoigne de quoi en terme de vol à
on va dire de de de de de petits de
petits vol qu'est-ce qui est le plus
ciblé est-ce que vous avez euu une
augmentation de vol sur certains
produits je vais vous dire franchement
non je ve dire non il y a ce sujet
existe un peu dans les médias
actuellement est-il véritablement un
phénomène qui a pris de l'ampleur moi je
dirais non de de notre point de vue on n
pas vu une explosion je dire de de
constat de vol en en sortie de caisse
dans nos magasins non euh par contre par
contre encore une fois nous on est très
prés dans les territoires ruraux à la
campagne souvent on se connaît davantage
il y a quand même un respect qui est
toujours là voilà maintenant dans
l'univers urbain j'ai des collègues qui
ont plus de difficultés mais je ne peux
pas vous dire ce soir que c'est un
phénomène qui a explosé après pour
répondre à votre question sur il
semblerait que certains magasins
s'équipent davantage oui mais ça c'est
c'est le sens de l'histoire depuis des
années on on protège davantage les
produits vendus dans les magasins ça
vient un peu des États-Unis et puis dans
le contexte actuel il y a pas il y a un
peu des reportages des choses qui sont
montrées mais mais il y a pas
massivement des steaks hachés ou des
steaks qui sont protégés et cetera on on
est attentif mais il y a pas d'explosion
de ce phénomène là mais par contre je
fais bien une distinction entre la
ruralité les campagnes et le le milieu
urbain où c'est parfois plus difficile
et clairement mes collègues qui habitent
enfin qui habitent qui qui ont leur
magasin en zone urbaine on doivent avoir
une équipe de gardienage et cetera mais
ça c'est c'est pas nouveau c'est dans
tous les magasins et c'est dans
l'univers
urbain on continue encore un petit peu
sur ce type de
sujet le marketing le le traçage des
clients la data les caméras de
vidéosurveillance les analyses de
données est-ce que vous dans vos magasin
vous avez par exemple des partenariats
avec certaines applications de téléphone
est-ce que vous achetez de la date ça
pour comprendre le comportement de vos
vos vos clients de vos consommateurs
est-ce que par exemple vous allez
installer de la reconnaissance de
comportement avec des logiciels dans vos
caméras est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
ce type de choses dans vos magasins
alors les technologies évoluent ce qui
est à notre disposition aussi mais où on
en est là-dessus il y a on a une mine
d'information dans notre métier la
grande distribution qui est qui sont les
ticketes caiss
ça c'est la base de notre travail
marketing où effectivement on sait que
telle famille a ce type de
dépenses quelle famille c'est c'est pas
de Mus non je veux dire que selon les
les catégories les catégories
socio-pressionnel il y a ce type de
d'achat après nous selon nos catégories
de fidélité en fait voilà c'est par la
carte de fidélité que tu étudies le
comportement de tes consommateurs mais
de manière générale et que tu peux après
leur proposer des choses qui
correspondent à leurs attentes nous tout
ce qui nous intéresse c'est ça c'est pas
individuellement et cetera c'est des
comportements d'achat pour
après proposer des choses qui vont les
intéresser qui vont donc stimuler le
chiffre d'affaires il y a tout ce volet
là mais qui existe depuis des années que
moi je considère on n'utilise pas à fond
et je pense qu'on pourrait mieux faire
avec l'intelligence artificielle qui
existe aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on y
travaille pour mieux utiliser cette
donnée je considère qu'on presque on
dort sur un trésor qui n'est pas assez
exploité on fait je dirais à minima ce
qui ce qu'il faut faire et je pense que
ça va progress Mina à minima par rapport
à vos concurrents non mais même je pense
même mes concurents il y en a qui sont
peut-être plus avancés que d'autres mais
mais globalement je pense qu'on utilise
pas assez ces données pour optimiser
notre travail il faudrait qu'on le fasse
mieux ça c'est la partie ticket caisse
après est-ce qu'on achète des données
oui on achète a un peu de données on
croise des données mais c'est toujours
des données anonymisées elles sont
anonymisées là moi je veux rassurer les
gens on croise des données pour encore
une foisir une meilleure connaissance
mais c'est jamais individuellement il
faut complètement rassuré sur il y a pas
de traçabilité ou ou quoi que ce soit en
aucun cas prier premier élément deuxième
élément tout ce qui tourne autour de la
vidéo il y a un petit sujet qui traîne
actuellement autour de ça il y a la
quasiment dans tous les magasins
aujourd'hui de la
vidéosurveillance la vidéo protection
mais qui est de la vidéo protection
absolument pour lutter contre contre la
ce qu'on appelle nous gentiment entre
guillemets la démarque
inconnue mais qui est beaucoup utilisé
de la manière suivante dans les grands
magasins les plus grands les
hypermarchés il peut y avoir une équipe
dédiée qui est en permanence derrière
les caméras pour surveiller tel allé les
alcools les produits sens et cetera dans
les plus petits magasins ce qui est la
majorité chez nous des cas c'est une
vidéo qui va être utilisée à postériori
c'est-à-dire il y a eu un événement dans
le magasin on retrouve un emballage d'un
produit cher et cetera à ce moment-là on
va regarder dans la vidéo pour voir ce
qui s'est passé et essayer d'identifier
le le sujet mais il y a pas de
surveillance en permanence le sujet
après de reconnaissance et cetera alors
là les règles sont très strictes en
France sont absolument contrôlé par
l'acnil et vous ne pouvez absolument
enfin nous on est très vigilant très
vigilant là-dessus on a même des
consignes au niveau groupe de dire ne
faites pas n'importe quoi parce que
parfois il y a des nouvelles solutions
technologiques qui permettent de faire
des choses plus poussées on ne on
conseille de ne pas le prendre
évidemment voilà voilà où on en est on
est on est on est prudent sur ces
sujets-là mais il y a pas de sujet chez
nous du tout de reconnaissance ou comme
ça à mon avis peut se passer à
l'étranger d'ailleurs à l'étranger
j'étais l'autre jour à
Monaco et j'ai découvert à Monaco qu'en
fait vous étiez dans quel hôtel à Monaco
euh alors il se trouve alors je sais
plus le nom avec votre carte bleu ou la
carte bleue de la boîte c'était payé
avec ma carte bleue
professionnelle professionnelle mais
j'ai j'ai découvert en discutant avec
les locaux que là la surveillance est
extrêmement forte quoi c'estàd que tout
est identifié que il y a des caméras
partout que que que si vous venez de
l'extérieur et cetera enfin mais c'est
Monaco c'est une principuté c'est un
autre mode de fonctionnement c'est fait
pour la sécurité je je cite cet exemple
parce que je l'ai vécu tout récemment
mais on est loin de tout ça chez nous et
on respecte les règles de vie privée et
d'ailleurs une précision qui est
intéressante pour tout le monde on a des
règles très strictes à respecter sur la
durée d'enregistrement des vidéos qu'on
fait dans nos magasins donc en gr on va
dire allez c'est une dizaine de jours
qui est archivé et après ça s efface
automatiquement et sauf sur réquisition
de la gendarmerie locale qui vous dit
vous enregistrez cette image les images
sont écrasées ne sont pas enregistrées
donc voyez il y a pas d'archivage il y a
pas de suivi rien du tout de tout ça
alors une petite parenthèse on passe le
bonjour au commissariat de Monaco qu'on
a eu au téléphone pour des questions de
renseignement et et et leur poser deux
trois questions et d'ailleurs ils
étaient très opér rationnel très sympa
très carré une charmante dame
d'ailleurs fin de la parenthèse pour
revenir au comportement d'achat par
exemple ça m'est arrivé en préparant
cette interview et ça m'est arrivé en en
allant faire mes courses dans un
supermarché concurrent du vôtre
désolé recevant de la pub pour un café
ouais parce que j'étais resté un peu
longtemps je pense devant le rayon en
question ça il y a pas ça chez vous pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout ah non
non il y a pas ah non non on n est pas
du tout là vous pourriez recevoir par
exemple en sortie de caisse chez nous un
coupon qui vous encourage à acheter un
certain café parce que à l'instant vous
venez d'acheter du café ça c'est
possible vous voyez il y a dans vos
achats du jour du café donc ça déclenche
un bon pour un autre café mais par
contre de la reconnaissance sur le fait
que vous ayez fait un geste qui enc pas
du tout pas du tout pas du tout Amazon
Amazon qui qui fait des des supermarchés
sans caissière sans personne à
l'intérieur ouais que j'ai visité aux
États-Unis notamment
alors j'y crois pas du tout j'y crois
pas du tout donc ça s'appelle alors
comment ça s'appelait Amazon rapide et
cetera donc par exemple à New York donc
vous rentrez c'est un un petit magasin
vous avez donc une toute petite surface
qui est bourrée de technologie ça ça
vous frappe immédiatement donc au
plafond il y a énormément de de caméras
là qui filment tout et cetera l'offre
est très courte c'est une offre je
dirais de dépan en pied d'immeuble New
Yorkais et vous faites votre tour vous
saisissez le produit vous êtes encarté
Amazon Prime en fait et puis la carte
probablement de ce service là vous
pouvez sortir et vous êtes tout ça est
enregistré directement sur votre compte
et débité sur votre compte sans aucune
interaction il y a pas de caissière il y
a rien et cetera mais les coulisses de
cette technologie c'est quoi c'est que
et ça on nous l'a expliqué quand on
était sur place c'est que effectivement
il y a personne dans le magasin mais il
y a une arrière boutique en fait où il y
a plusieurs techniciens qui font tourner
toute cette technologie en permanence
donc je dirais presque les bras que tu
n'as pas dans le magasin tu les as en en
en en en coulisse et et quand on regarde
alors j'ai demandé mais qu'achètent les
gens dans ce magasin et cetera et ben il
nous il nous disait en fait ils viennent
surtout boire un café parce qu'il y
avait plusieurs machines à café des
boissons c'est ça qu'ils achetaient le
plus les gens faisaient vraiment pas euh
leurs courses là-dedans et d'ailleurs la
plupart de ces magasins euh beaucoup ont
fermé déjà parce que le modèle
économique n'est pas au rendez-vous la
technologie coûte encore extrêmement
cher l'assortiment est court votre
chiffre d'affair et la marche que vous
en dégagez ne couvre pas les frais
d'exploitation du point de vente donc
ils ont reculé c'est plutôt des vitrines
technologie qui permettent d'avancer des
technologies mais qui seront à mon avis
pas le modèle de demain ou en tout cas
pas à court
terme d'autres détails à nous
communiquer concernant ce type de
technologie où on repart sur l'inflation
la géopolitique non sur les technologies
il y a une chose qui me vient encore à
l'esprit et qui elle par contre aura
plus de sens c'est par exemple de la
vidéo pour analyser les ruptures en
magasin donc je m'explique des caméras
au-dessus des rayons qui repère que un
moment il manque un produit il y a un
trou ce qu'on appelle un trou dans le
rayon il manque une référence et là ça
lance une alerte à l'équipe de
remplissage pour dire attention il y a
plus tel café il faut vite aller le
remplir parce qu'il y en a plus ça c'est
le genre de technologie qui a plus de
sens plus que toutes les reconnaissances
individuelles qui pour moi ne sont pas
le sujet pour l'instant voilà pas de
fliquage de vos salariés avec ça mais en
aucun cas et on a'urait pas le droit
mais non mais non bien sûr que non non
et attention euh quand vous mettez un
système de vidéo protection comme on a
dit dans le magasin vous êtes obligé
d'en informer vos représentants du
personnel aujourd'hui votre CSE comité
social et économique en toute
transparence leur dire et cetera c'est
très réglementé très organisé donc on ne
joue pas du tout avec ça on peut être
également contrôlé par la gendarmerie il
y a un dossier en préfecture qui est
très enregistré sur le nombre de caméras
non on ne rigole absolument pas avec ce
genre de
sujet on passe vous savez quand j'ai
préparé cette interview j'ai un peu
bourlingué sur vos vidéos sur vos
anciennes campagnes de pub
non a une pub sympa avec Noël et un
petit vieux là ah celleà elle est très
sympa une pube de Noël il y a 3 4 ans
ouais celle-ci
elle est super vraiment je et super donc
c'est c'est c'est pour faire passer un
message que vous êtes proche de vos
clients mais c'était ça on était un soir
de Noël le monsieur était enfin faisait
ses courses le le magasin allait fermé
et
le patron mon collègue se rend compte
que ce monsieur allait passer son Noël
seul il n'avait plus de famille ses
enfants n'avaient pas pu venir et cetera
et donc a décidé de de de transformer
magasin en restaurant d'un soir pour
Noël pour accueillir ce client qui a
Sant fêté Noël tout seul oui donc
c'était une belle histoire mais c'est
mais c'est une histoire vraie
ou c'est romancé c'est pas une histoire
vraie mais cette proximité avec nos
clients avec l'ensemble de nos partie
prenante c'est la marque de fabrique de
Hu c'est dire on est impliqué dans le
territoire souvent pour des années
parfois de père en fils c'est mon cas
moi c'est une entreprise familiale mais
je ne suis pas le seul dans la région
Ouest la région historique de U les
magasins euh sont sont de de père en
fils ou de de père en fille et donc on
connaît nos clients pendant depuis très
longtemps on vit avec eux on viit avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes on est
des grands soutiens des associations
locales on connaît les politiques locaux
les clubs sportifs évidemment on les
soutient de près donc cette interaction
que symbolisait ce film c'est une
réalité dans dans dans nos magasins on
est très attentif à ça on reviendra
peut-être sur ce type de sujet un peu
plus tard on va passer à la géopolitique
on va passer à l'inflation du à au
contexte géopolitique euh en 2022
euh juin 2022 on grâce à notre
communauté on est et et à à quelques
amis on est au courant que les les que
certains supermarchés faisaient des
réunions pour de l'anticipation
d'inflation de l'anticipation par
rapport au vol l'anticipation par
rapport à tout ça et les chiffres qui
qui nous ont été remontés c'était entre
20 % d'inflation et 40 % d'inflation fin
2024 on est à
21,5 sur 2 ans sur 2 ans j'ai une
question à vous poser vous est-ce que
vous utilisez des officines des cabinets
d'intelligence économique pour faire de
la prospective de
l'anticipation qui pourrait vous toucher
à l'échelle géopolitique ou à l'échelle
locale est-ce que vous faites du
renseignement économique chez vos
concurrents ou vous tenez au courant de
nouvelles tendances mais bien sûr on se
tient au courant en
permanence des tendances euh on on on
achète des données euh bien sûr pour
pour faire notre propre analyse et et au
bout du compte établir notre propre
stratégie mais je vais vous dire quelque
chose moi je suis président de systu
depuis mai 2018 depuis que je suis
président de systemu je vais de crise en
crise la crise du covid la crise de
l'inflation on a un moment eu une crise
interne et cetera donc je vais vous dire
vous pouvez acheter toutes les données
du monde à un moment les prévisions en
ce moment elles sont très très
difficiles euh comment dire à à
déterminer et et à assurer et ce qui est
ce qui peut être vrai à un moment à une
à un moment T est bouleversé par un
événement
géopolitique imprévu qui remet en cause
ton analyse et qui donc je ve dire le
rythme le rythme des transformations le
rythme des remises en cause le rythme
des des rebondissements de tous ordres
fait que il est très difficile de
stabiliser
aujourd'hui comment dire une position et
d'ailleurs pour moi le maître mot de la
période qu'on vit actuellement c'est un
instabilité stabilité incontestablement
c'est la période n'est pas stable et ça
je le dis pu ça fait longtemps que je
fais ce métier pendant des années
c'était extrêmement stable le modèle
était extrêmement réglé
euh c'était simple on pourrait le
détailler hein d'ailleurs euh euh on le
détaille on le détaille donc non vous
avez du temps j'ai du
temps ce système de grande distribution
qui est né aller dans dans les années 60
euh comment dire c'était proposer en
masse des produits à des clients qui
venaient en grand nombre dans nos
magasins c'est tout tout a commencé
comment par le ce premier supermarché
qui s'est à un moment installé en
périphérie de ville et qui a accompagné
alors souvent on nous dit oui mais c'est
vous qui êtes sorti de la ville pour
vous installer en périphérie de ville et
qui avait d'ailleurs modifié du coup le
paysage de la ville c'est pas ça
l'histoire c'est pas ça l'histoire le
début l'histoire c'est quoi c'est que
les gens qui habitaient avant dans la
ville ont commencé à s'équiper de
voitures individuelles c'est la voiture
individuelle achetée par les Français
par la classe moyenne française qui du
jour au lendemain a eu la liberté
d'avoir cette voiture s'est déplacé du
cœur de ville vers la périphérie parce
que qui dit qui dit voiture dit ben il
faut un garage il faut une belle petite
maison pour pour avoir ça et ça ça a
développé les périphéries ville et nous
on est allé s'installer là où ces gens
se sont déplacés c'est pas nous qui ne
nous sommes déplacés ce sont d'abord les
Français donc on a accompagné ce
mouvement et donc ce modèle- là il a
duré pendant 40 50 ans de manière très
réglée avec des relations avec des
industriels qui produisaient en grande
quantité des produits qu'on leur
achetait des promotions et cetera et
depuis allez on va dire un peu une
dizaine d'années ce modèle a
complètement été bouleversé par plein de
donnes et et
aujourd'hui voilà on vit un système
complètement différent pendant les 40
premières années je dirais j'aurais
envie de dire que nous avions le pouvoir
nous les entreprises et peut-être les
marques face au consommateurs on avait
le pouvoir parce que il y avait moins
d'informations et cetera et depuis
quelques années pour moi le schéma c'est
complètement inversé et c'est le client
qui a le pouvoir le client qui a le
pouvoir parce qu'il est mieux informé
parce qu'il a un smartphone qui fait que
quand il est en magasin il peut à tout
moment checker ce qu'il veut faire un
comparatif chercher un prix avoir des
informations avoir des notes d'une
communauté et cetera il a pris le
pouvoir sur nous et donc nous on
s'adapte aujourd'hui à ça et ça c'est
l'exemple majeur mais il y a plein
d'autres choses il y a internet et la
vente en ligne qui a complètement
bouleversé on pourrait encore une fois
détailler ça très très très très
longuement revenons sur inelligence
économique vos datas vous les acheté où
par qui comment quel type de
pipe pour nous c'est c'est c'est des
choses très classiques hein c'est les ce
sont les ce qu'on appelle les panélistes
français des gens comme circa des gens
comme Nilsen à qui on achète des données
eux ils étudient l'ensemble du marché et
et là c'est des données très
professionnelles sur la consommation
c'est ça qui nous intéresse je dirais
avant tout après on fait une veille plus
générale de l'actualité
au au sens au sens large on participe à
notre fédération notre fédération la
Fédération du commerce et la
distribution qui réunit un certain
nombre d'acteurs et organisé en groupe
de de travail qui justement
approfondiss chaque sujet le social les
relations avec l'agriculture tac tac tac
et qui fait un espèce en permanence
d'état de l'art des
informations à connaître et donc on on
utilise beaucoup cette source là et
après il y a l'échange entre nous tous
et cetera c'est plus ça mais mais voilà
nous on est très comment dire un groupe
de supermarchés et d'hypermarchés
français en cré 80 % de vos produits
sont français 80 % des produits à la
marque U qui est notre marque celle
qu'on fait fabriquer absolument sont
fabriqués à base de produits français et
par des entreprises françaises et
essentiellement des PME on a un ancrage
là et donc je veux dire de
l'intelligence internationale moi je
n'en je n'en achète pas voilà pour
répondre à la question
c'est vous faites de la veille à
l'internationale oou il y a des gens qui
font de la veille à l'internationale
pour vous oui dans votre boîte vous vous
sous-traitez là on sous-traite par
exemple là pour le coup on fait par
exemple partie de la Fédération des
commerçants indépendant européen qui
elle fait une veille au niveau européen
et là où je vais régulièrement euh
participer où je rencontre mes confrères
européens on est où on échange à un
niveau européen donc vous voyez le
niveau français avec beaucoup le travail
en Fédération le travail avec les
collègues euh le niveau européen pour
avoir une vision plus globale euh et
puis après dernier point euh
régulièrement des échanges avec les
pouvoirs publics quand même euh pendant
la crise euh du du du
covid-19 alors ça c'est un grand sujet
aussi euh l'obsession qu'on a tous un
gros barnom quand
même un barnom vous
dites non parce que la chaîne
agroalimentaire française aurait pu
craquer il faut se le redire donc il
faut raconter cette histoire il faut
raconter cette histoire du jour au
lendemain la France décide de se
confiner c'était le 16 mars 2020 ils
vous ont prévenu un peu avant ou pas bah
pas du tout pas pas non mais pas du tout
on voyait monter le sujet en puissance
on savait que ça pouvait venir mais mais
cette histoire de confinement est
arrivée très très vite donc du jour au
lendemain tout le monde se confine reste
ouvert nos magasins mais dans des
conditions draconiennes d'accès de de
distance fallait faire la queue devant
les magasins et cetera et et donc à
partir de là il y a eu une fragilisation
global de de la chaîne agroalimentaire
je peux vous couper ouais avant avant ça
c'est-à-dire avant le le le fait que
l'État vous préviennent que c'était euh
on on confinait euh euh vous avez vu et
on a vu des des gens faire la queue pour
faire des provisions en mode c'est la
guerre
oui la fameuse image de des rouleaux de
PC papier toilette excusez-moi euh
racontez-moi ça et ensuite on repasse à
la là où je vous a recoupéord
oui il y a une espèce de de de de de
montée en tension en disant voilà on va
être confiné faites des provisions tout
ne sera peut-être plus accessible et là
on a vécu une journée titanesque la
veille du confinement je dire on a on a
battu des records de chiffres d'affaires
puisque les gens se sont précipités pour
truc mais ça a été une journée très
difficile moi je me souviens mon chef
boucher dans mon magasin il s'appelle
comment Thierry mais il est parti à la
retraite Thierry d'accord
mais combien 40 ans de vie
professionnelle dans mon entreprise
formidable un gars comme ça un grand
professionnel de son métier il m'a dit
Dominique la journée que j'ai vécu est
la pire journée de de de ma vie
professionnelle les gens s'arrachaient
les produits dans les rayons il y avait
plus aucun respect ce jour-là il y avait
un espèce de sentiment de panique j'ai
besoin de mon produit je veux mon
produit le voisin je m'en fous et les
gens ne ce jour-là parce ça n'arrive pas
autrement ne respectait plus les
collaborateurs enfin c'était panique à
bord donc ça c'est vrai ça c'est vrai
mais ça a duré une journée ça ça a duré
une journée après on est rentré dans ce
que j'ai décrit le phénomène suivant
mais là où je veux en venir outre euh
ces moments incroyables que nous avons
vécu euh dans les magasins c'est cette
fragilisation de la chaîne
agro-alimentaire parce que quand les
gens restent à la maison nonont plus euh
ne peuvent plus se déplacer ou comme
avant ou avec des des attestations et
cetera ça a perturbé les producteurs
dans les champs les les agriculteurs ça
a perturbé la fabrication dans les
usines il y a des gens il y avait plus
assez de bras parfois dans les usines ça
a perturbé les livraisons toute cette
chaîne a été perturbé et
donc Bruno le particulièrement nous
réunissait régulièrement pour s'assurer
que cette chaîne alimentaire ne craque
pas
ettienne
et et à un moment monte puissance cette
idée que les industriels n'ont plus
assez de bras pour produire il nous le
disait on était dans ces réunions où on
échangeait ben les équipes ne viennent
plus je peux plus produire et cetera
résultat dernier vendredi du mois de
mars 2020 Bruno leemire nous dit
messieurs
euh je sens que on est au bord du craque
euh préparez le plan
B le plan préparez vos plans B chaque
dans vos entreprises je vous reconvoque
lundi on en reparle lundi on travaille
de manière acharnée tout un weekend sur
le plan B comment on peut faire pour
quand même trouver de la marchandise et
cetera les producteurs de leur côté
comment trouver des bras et cetera on
s'est retrouvé le lundi par je ne sais
quel
miracle tout le monde avait trouvé plus
ou moins des solutions des bras des des
intérimaires quand même des étudiants
subitement c'était proposé pour bah vous
n'avez pas vos collaborateurs habituels
on vient vous aider on vient il y a une
espèce aussi de de de mouvement de
solidarité pour que tout le monde se
sert lesécoute que la chaîne ne craque
pas et elle n'a pas craqué mais elle
aurait pu craquer et imaginez un instant
que il y a plus de quoi se nourrir dans
un magasin et et la panique ça aurait
été la panique totale et ça aurait pu
l'être et je peux vous dire qu'à ce
moment-là j'ai touché du doigt
l'importance de notre métier l'Ance de
notre métier je veux dire on est souvent
caricaturé on est souvent comment on est
caricaturé comme un métier pas
intéressant être au test de caisse
remplir des rayons c'est pas intéressant
certains disent c'est mal payé mais ça
on pourra en reparler c'est pas vrai
combien vous touchez pardon combien vous
gagnez moi combien je gagne je gagne le
salaire d'un cadre sup c'est
combien est-ce que c'est très important
de le dire franchement je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas euh je ne suis pas quelqu'un
du je ne suis pas un patron du CAC 40
d'accord qui gagne des millions c'est
pas mon cas euh je suis président d'une
coopérative de commerceant indépendant
c'est une coopérative làedans j'ai un
salaire de cadre supérieur voilà c'est
c'est pas un un salaire du tout en
millions du tout du tout du tout et donc
euh et donc voilà on est on est très
caricaturé mais là pendant cette crise
on a touché du doit la beauté de notre
métier et l'importance de ce que c'est
nourrir les Français et donc je je cite
il m'est arrivé de citer plusieurs fois
cet exemple mais qui me tient vraiment à
cœur j'avais à à l'époque dans mon
magasin mais c'est vrai dans le mien
mais dans plein de magasins en France
trois hôèes de caisse qui avaient 60 ans
ces trois femmes qui faisaient ce métier
depuis de longues années auraient pu
dire je suis collaborateur sensible je
me mets en retrait les personnes les
plus âgées pour pouvit quitter le
travail elles ne l'ont pas fait et elles
ne l'ont jamais fait elles ont été
présentes du premer au dernier jour en
me disant Dominique je seraai pas
absente je veux être là je veux aider
les Français je veux aider mes clients
elles avaient leurs masques elles ont
été exemplaires elles sont pas tombées
malade par chance c'était formidable et
ça ça a donné une piqûure de sens
formidable à toutes les équipes dans
notre métier dans mon entreprise dans
notre métier en général et ça même
postcovid réattirer des jeunes vers la
coopérative qui ont dit ben je pose ma
candidature bah parce que finalement ça
a du sens de bosser chez vous et ça
c'était
génial une petite prime pour vos hôesses
de caisse à la suite elles l'ont eu
elles l'ont eu elles l'ont eu mais bien
sûr déjà grosse prime alors mais
écoutez souvent souvent c'est tout ça
est caricaturé dans notre profession
déjà on a une branche qui est très
active la branche professionnelle la
branche une branche c'est quoi il faut
expliquer c'est les
représentants des entreprises et les
représentants des salariés c'est ça une
branche ces gens se voient régulièrement
pour discuter des conditions sociales
appliquées dans la branche donc chez
nous la branche de la grande
distribution on a une branche des plus
dynamique un nos minimas sociaux euh
comment dire il y a des branches qui
sont en dessous des minimas sociaux
c'est pas notre cas c'est une des
branches qui a le plus revu les salaires
ces derniers temps ça a été revu
régulière
nous sommes une branche où les gens sont
payés sur 13 mois de salaire 13 mois et
pas et pas 12 donc il y a un 13e mois
nous sommes une branche également où
dans bien des entreprises il y a la
participation au résultats et donc cette
participation au résultat peut
facilement faire un demi-mois de salaire
jusqu'à un mois de salaire et dans les
meilleures entreprises même plus donc il
peut arriver que vous soyez payé non pas
13 mois 13 mois et demi 14 mois voire 15
mois dans les meilleures entreprises et
ça c'est pas dit c'est pas dit ça vous
utilisez pas des CDD renouvelables à
chaque fois alors oui on a aussi une
image effectivement de conditions pas
bonne mais je vais vous dire si vous
pratiquez encore ça trop aujourd'hui
vous vous vous vous n'avez plus les
collaborateurs les gens partent donc le
chef d'entreprise qui ne se remet pas en
cause qui ne remet pas en cause sa
politique salariale ça sa sa façon de
fidéliser ses collaborateurs qui n'est
pas à jour de toutes ces questionsl il
se disqualifie lui-même et il n'a pas
les collaborateurs pour travailler je ne
dis pas qu'il n'y en a pas encore dans
notre métier je suis lucide mais je
pense que ça a beaucoup évolué et que si
vous ne faites pas ce qu'il faut vous
n'avez pas les collaborateurs pour
travailler pour vous et donc pardon mais
je réponds encore à votre question oui
il y a eu des primes euh à l'époque ça
s'appelait prime Macron et et maintenant
ça s'appelle prime de partage de la
valeur c'était une prime que l'on
donnait qui était qui était pas taxé et
qui a permis de récompenser les gens et
il y a eu des primes Macron très
largement pendant cette période làà pour
saluer les efforts des hôesses de caisse
des gens qui ont rempl les rayons parce
que j'ai parlé des hôesses de caisse
mais j'aurais pu saluer tous les autres
qui ont été
formidables ça fait du bien d'entendre
ça de temps en temps mais oui mais ça
fait du bien il faut le dire aussi il
faut le dire que que les gens étaient
super mobilisés pour les Français et et
alors je je dis aussi pendant cette
période on a reçu des des
merci vous vous nous servez tous les
jours bravo pour ce que vous faites pour
nous et cetera et puis et puis je sais
pas 6 mois plus tard 1 an plus tard ben
l'ambiance sétait retourné et puis il y
avait de nouveau eu plus d'agressivité
et puis tout ça ça a été vite oublié le
le temps passe vite et puis on passe
vite à autre chose c'est ça aussi que je
veux dire mais n'empêche ce moment
restera là à tout jamais dans nos
mémoires revenons aux cellules de
prospective revenons à l'anticipation on
prend l'exemple du covid on pourrait
prendre l'exemple des révolutions arabes
on pourrait prendre l'exemple de la
guerre avec la
Russie première question donc le covid
on vous a lâché en race campagne du
genre demain tu fermes où tu tu
appliques ce type de de chos
c'est-à-dire que la communication entre
le gouvernement et vous c'était un petit
peu vous m'aviez dit mars c'est ça
c'était fin mars ouais et et vous avec
votre votre propre cellule de
prospective et d'anticipation de
renseignement économique est-ce que vous
aviez vu l'émergence du covid d'une
façon beaucoup plus agressive je vous
donne un exemple
nous à partir du 17 janvier on était au
courant que ça partait en sucette en
Chine les points de contrôle les
checkpint des quartiers pauvres qui se
faisaient fermer avec des Bar à min
soudé devant leur porte avec juste
l'espace pour pouvoir passer un sac de
course vous l'aviez senti venir avant
l'état vous avez été prévenu avant
l'état éc moi moi je vais vous dire un
truc je moi personnellement
personnellement dans mon boulot de
président moi j'ai une obsession
c'est c'est c'est c'est d'essayer
d'avoir un coup d'avance je dire moi
c'est pourquoi un TR c'est mieux oui ou
même trois bien sûr mais c'est c'est
c'est d'être en avance c'est d'anticiper
moi j'ai une obsession je considère
qu'une de mes responsabilités c'est
d'anticiper de voir plus loin et et et
peut-être avant avant les autres et je
je je dois reconnaître que je suis assez
à l'aise dans la gestion des crises de
manière générale alors je ne les
souhaite pas mais mais force de
constater avec le temps puisque j'en ai
vécu quelques-unes maintenant que c'est
plutôt à l'aise et du coup j'ai aussi
peut-être appris à essayer d'anticiper
davantage les choses et cette histoire
de covid moi dès alors peut-être pas le
17 janvier mais peut-être début février
vraiment fin janvier début février j'ai
commencé à alerter les équipes chez moi
vraiment avec un certain nom d'image
qu'on avait d'éléments qui qui qui qui
qui qui nous venaient de manière plus
précise je suis beaucoup oup sur les
réseaux sociaux et cetera il y avait
quand même beaucoup de choses très
précises qui étaient déjà là mais à un
moment j'étais regardé comme un
extraterrestre et c'était ça la la la la
difficulté et par qui même par mes
équipes à moi en disant mais Dominique
tu vas trop loin tu tu tu as trop peur
tu tu tu tu tu es trop inquiétant et
j'ai insisté on a mis en place voilà
effectivement les les la le début de
cellule de crise à ce moment et cetera
pour c'est quelle période ça avant
l'état là on est on est oui oui on est
en février on est en février puisqu'il y
avait il y avait des premiers impacts on
commence à voir des choses choses sur la
chaîne d'approvisionnement et cetera
donc on a commencé à s'organiser à ce
moment-là mais là ce qui m'a fait
plaisir c'est que quelques temps plus
tard les mêmes qui m'ont dit mais
Dominique tu vas trop loin tu vois trop
loin et cetera m'ont dit mais Dominique
tu avais raison et j'ai eu raison très
tôt sur ce ce coup-là mais je considère
mais j'en tire aucune gloire je veux
dire je considère que c'est mon boulot
c'est la gestion du bon père de famille
alsacien c'est ça mais c'est plein de
choses c'est un anticipé gestion bon
père de famille je considère je
considère que j'ai la responsabilité
ultime de cette coopérative et et et et
des gens que j'ai autour de moi et et je
cherche à mettre en place les outils et
et ce qu'il faut pour prendre les
meilleures décisions au moment voulu
voilà c'est ça ma responsabilité la
guerre en Ukraine la guerre avec les
Russes euh votre cellule de prospective
d'anticipation l'avait senti venir avait
avait euh
né sur les conséquences que ça allait
avoir sur le terme de l'inflation est-ce
que vous avez suivi l'évolution du
conflit à partir de 2014 est-ce que vous
aviez une cellule dédiée parce que
l'Ukraine production de céréales
l'Ukraine nœ gazier l'Ukraine qui se
fâche avec les Russes 25 % de l'énergie
européenne est-ce que vous aviez des
gens opérationnels sur ce type de
conflit géopolitique non là là pour le
coup non on avait ça dans les radars
mais on on avait pas
mesuré l'impact dans cette ampleur là du
sujet mais si vous voulez bien il faut
revenir un peu avant puisque votre
question derrière tout ça c'est
l'inflation il faut comprendre que ma
question derrière tout ça c'est certes
l'inflation mais c'est surtout protéger
le business français oui oui parce que
accessoirement ça protge les Français et
accessoirement ça protège les Français
donc juste il faut retirer le fil
complet de ce qu'on a vécu et et et des
démarrages de l'inflation aussi pour
comprendre et et pour en tirer les
leçons et peut-être faire mieux une
prochaine
fois mais alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé on a vécu cette crise du covid qui
a déréglé les chaînes agro-alimentaires
et tiens je peux vous donner un chiffre
un chiffre interne hein vous aimez les
sources un chiffre interne avant le
covid le taux de rupture donc de de
produit qui manquaent dans un magasin
comme le mien enfin nos magasins c'était
2 % sur l'ensemble des produits manquait
en moyenne 2 % parce que le fournisseur
n'a pas livré parce que il manquait une
matière première et cetera et cetera
pendant le covid tout ça c'est déréglé
on est monté à 10 12 % et ben depuis on
arrive pas à redescendre truc on est
plus du tout à 2 on doit être je crois
actuellement à 7 8 mais on narrive pas à
redescendre à 2 il y a quelque chose qui
s'est dérgl rgl durablement depuis donc
déjà premier point la crise du covid
dérègle la chaîne agroalimentaire tiens
je prends un exemple très intéressant
aussi les industriels quand ils avaient
les problèmes de main- d'œuvre que j'ai
décrit tout à l'heure ils ont commencé à
dire bon j'ai pas mes 50 personnes qui
produisent habituellement j'en ai que 35
qu'est-ce que je fais comment je
m'organise ils ont fait des choix de
rationalisation et ils ont dit au lieu
de produire euh le le le le fabricant de
gâteau qui dit j'ai 50 produits dans ma
gamme pendant cette crise je n'en
produis plus que 25 euh les 25 plus
importants et eu truc et donc 25
produits ont manqué du jour au lendemain
dans les rayons et et les gens se sont
habitués à ça mais quand le covid s'est
estompé que c'est redevenu à la normale
certains ont dit mais est-ce que c'est
encore du sens de produire 50 produits
différents avec des petites spécialités
et cetera il y en a qui se sont jamais
forcément mis à tout reproduire vous
voyez donc il a il y a il y a des choses
qui ont commencé à dérègler cette chaîne
dans cet espritl euh voilà donc déjà
premier premier point deuxième point à
un moment après après le covid qui avait
vraiment tassé l'économie ralenti
l'économie l'économie subitement à la
fin de l'année 2021 a redémarré de
manière drastique d'un seul coup et là
ça a mis une première tension
inflationniste sur sur beaucoup de
choses puisque du jour au lendemain la
demande c'est'est
accéléré notamment par exemple aussi
dans la construction et et et j'en sais
quelque chose à ce moment-là moi
j'agrandissais mon magasin j'étais en
train de négocier d'importants travaux
d'agrandissement avec des charpente et
cetera et ben les entreprises étaient
très sollicité par la reprise tu n'en
trouvais pas leurs matériaux de
construction explosait du jour au
lendemain parce que tout le monde en
voulait en même temps pour rire tout ce
qui n'avait pas été construit pendant
les confinements et et donc on s'est
pris par exemple sur des constructions
des des des surcoups de 20 à 25 % ça
c'est le début de l'inflation en France
fin 2021 et en février 2022 quand
démarre la guerre en Ukraine bah tout ça
s'aggrave et on se rend compte à ce
moment-là là j'avoue j'avoue que que
queil y a pas eu il y a pas eu
d'anticipation de de de l'ampleur de
l'impact de la production en Ukraine sur
sur tout par souvent on me dit oui mais
il y a une question que mais quand même
est-ce que vraiment l'Ukraine à ce point
avait tout déréglé ben oui en fait oui
le
Tournesol vient énormément d'Ukraine
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a manqué
d'huile de tournesol dans nos rayons
incontestablement je peux vous arrêter
une seconde pendant la crise de l'huile
du tournesol l'augmentation du prix de
l'huile l'augmentation du de la moutarde
des gens passaient des meilleurs la
moutarde Canada ça c'est Canada on peut
expliquer aussi ouou et puis aussi
conteneur en verre mais c'est c'est un
autre problème vous voyez de quoi je
parle tout fait tout à fait ok donc sur
l'Ukraine est-ce qu'il y a eu des
industriels qui ont fait de la rétention
et qu' on fait des marges ou des des des
plusvalues aurissante en période de
guerre parce que il y avait de l'huile
d'olive au Portu il y avait de l'huile
de tournesol au port
Portugal je vais pas citer de marque
mais mais est-ce qu'il y a des
industriels est-ce que vous sentez qu'il
a des industriels qui ont en profité
mais on est là dans un phénomène après
économique complètement classique
c'est-à-dire que à la base à la base il
y a eu de vraies tensions li à de vrais
manques à de vraies ruptures de la
chaîne il y a plus de tournsol qui
arrive ça manque il y a plus de pot en
vert on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup
de pot en ver était produit euh en
Ukraine
euh s mêlé l'histoire ensuite
effectivement de la moutarde c'est venu
très vite après l'huile mais là c'est un
problème de production de la graine de
moutarde au Canada qui avait subi des
intempéries il y avait plus de graines
de moutarde en production et cetera tout
ça s'est cumulé ça c'est les facteurs
générateurs à la base réel constatés
effectif après au-delà de ça que
certains acteurs mais mais je dirais à
la marge
profite de la situation et bloque des
quantités ou et ça ça peut-être mais
pour moi ça ce n'était pas généralisé
c'était ponctuel mais il y avait à la
base de de vrais phénomènes de rupture
de chaînes d'approvisionnement de
blocage de camion qui ne circulaient
plus et cetera et cetera après il y a
peut-être des acteurs qui profitent et
après qu'est-ce qui se passe le marché
régule les choses le marché régule les
choses quand il y a des excès et ben les
produits sont boudés et cetera et le
marché se régule donc on est face à des
phénomènes somme toutes économique je
dirais relativement classique sauf que
ça faisait 40 ans qu'on avait pas connu
ça en France particulièrement depuis la
crise des années 70 avec une inflation
incroyable on avait plus connu donc on
avait perdu tous ces repères perdu t
premier choc
pétrolierers 70 premers choc pétrolier
il y a eu des petites périodes
d'inflation mais mais la vraie crise
inflationiste la dernière
particulièrement dans les produits de
grande consommation ça faisait 40 ans et
donc les
phénomènes qui qui sont somme toutes
classique et qu'on a parfois on a
parfois dit oui
mais voilà il y avait plus de repères
les j'en avait plus de repère et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs juste une
anecdote on adore les anecdotes vrai
pour gérer tout ça pour gérer tout ça
dans des entreprises comme les nôtres il
faut des acheteurs qui ont l'habitude de
gérer l'inflation euh et et de trouver
des sources d'approvisionnement
parallèle et cetera mais nos jeunes gars
acheteurs et cetera qui n'avaient pas
connu la la on avait plus personne qui
avait l'expérience de ça et donc il a
fallu reconstruire et je vais vous dire
on a même passé des coups de fil au plus
ancien qui avit connu les années 70 pour
dire mais comment vous aviez fait on en
était là il y a aussi eu ça
donc vraiment moi je j'insiste des
éléments structurels de base qui ont
déclencher la crise après peut-être des
phénomènes d'opportunisme de la part de
certains mais pour moi pas généralisés
et et après une régulation économique
globale qui se met en place et voilà et
les Français sont lucides si le produit
devient trop cher et ben ils ne
l'achètent plus et il se ils se déporent
sur autre chose et il et ils ont
raison le français est pas bête hein
mais il est très lucide souvent plus
lucide que la majeure partie de nos
ministres j'ai l'impression
c'était gratuit mais on a
envie on parlait des petits pots on
parlait de l'énergie vous parliez du
premier choc pétrolier qui a créé de
l'inflation en France et d'ailleurs
ailleurs parlons d'énergie vaau charge
elles ont explosé de combien parce que
entre les frigos les congélateurs
l'éclairage les ordinateurs le
chauffage c'est énorme vous avez raison
on a été nous-même touchés par par cette
crise de de de l'énergie et pourtant
chez Système U on achète l'électricité
de manière groupée c'est-à-dire on se
met tous ensemble vous des communiste
c'est pour ça ah non mais écoutez nous
c'est tout simple on est né en 1894 je
peux faire une parenthèse d'histoire
bien sûr Dominique on est né en
1894 al vous me changerez mon mot de
passe en alsacien après d'accord j'ai
besoin de changer mon mot de passe et je
veux le mettre en alsacien d'accord ok
on est né en 1880 14 à savenet à côté de
Nantes un épicier qui dit ouh là là que
se passe-t-il il y a des grands magasins
à Nantes qui commencent à vendre des
produit pas cher euh et nous on va pas
résister si on s'organise pas ils se
sont mis à 10 petits épiciers dans un
coin à se mettre ensemble pour dire ben
on va être aussi malin queeux on va
mettre nos quantités ensemble on va
acheter ensemble pour que ça nous coûte
moins cher plus tu achète un gros volume
à un fournisseur plus il te fait un prix
c'est du bon sens c'est extrêmement
basique
et ben notre histoire notre histoire
n'est n'est que ça notre histoire n'est
n'est que ça et donc ce qui ce que mes
prédécesseurs ont fait en 1894 de se
mettre ensemble pour acheter moins cher
être plus fort ensemble c'est exactement
ce qu'on continue à faire aujourd'hui et
ça n'a pas changé quoi ça n'a pas changé
revenons à l'électricité vous vous
l'chetez en groupeou donc on se met
ensemble pour acheter l'électricité
comme faisait mes mes prédécesseurs vos
aïeux pardon vos aïeux mes aïeux et et
donc en en gros notre facture
d'électricité a doublé a doublé en
2023 cette année ça va aller un tout
petit peu mieux mais mais l'impact
économique pour nous pour nos PME je
rappelle que chacun est responsable de
son c'est son entreprise est responsable
de son compte d'exploitation votre
facture d'élecité double chez moi 130000
€ devient 260000
€ il faut en vendre des baguettes et des
boîtes de conserves pour payer les
130000 € supplément quand on claque 100
€ chez vous vous mettez 2 € dans la
poche c'est ça exactement vous avez bien
écouté là aussi sortons des caricature
la Une des caricatures autour de la
grande distribution c'est ces garsl ils
s'en mettent plein les poches mais moi
c'est pas du tout ce que je v pourquoi
on entend les producteurs dire voilà les
producteurs laitiers les producteurs
disent les super les supermarchés le
kilo de pomme ils vendent ça 4 balles on
leur vaut 50
centimes
la marque de fabrique de c'est
caricatural mais mais ça y ressemble
quand même un peu oui mais mais c'est le
discours qu'on entend vous avez raison
de de de de le relayer non je le relie
pas je je ne le relaye pas je vous
demande de d'y réagir ouais ouais
euh comment dire notre métier c'est un
métier de péréquation je
m'explique on achète une multitude de
produits et on les revend et donc sur
chacun de ces produits on prend une
marge mais cette marge elle va être
différente d'un rayon à un autre
à certains endroits sur les produits les
plus vendus par exemple la bouteille de
Coca-Cola qui est très bataillée parce
que tout le monde beaucoup de gens
achètent une bouteille de Coca-Cola et
veulent un bon prix on va prendre très
peu de marge très peu de marge voire sur
certains grands produits quasiment rien
on ne gagne rien et par contre sur
d'autres produits on va prendre un peu
plus de marge et donc on on appelle ça
la péréquation des marges sur l'ensemble
mais au bout du compte ça c'est pour
tire à quoi à ce que vous avez dit
c'est-à-dire que sur 100 € dépensé dans
un de nos magasins en moyenne au
commerçant il reste 2 €. il en reste pas
20 il n'en reste pas 25 il n'en reste
même pas 15 il en reste 2 €. par contre
dans le monde industriel à minima c'est
le double si vous achetez euh 100 € de
produit d'une industrie moyenne il va
rester au moins 4 à 5 € et si vous
achetez 100 € de produit d'une
multinationale genre allez nestley genre
Coca-Cola il va rester 15 16 17 18 €.
donc ma question est où est la valeur où
est la valeur on croit souvent qu'elle
est chez nous elle est pas forcément le
plus chez nous et c'estes 2 € qui
restent donc 2 % de résultat net moi je
vous le dis donc c'est en baisse et
c'est en baisse c'est pas moi qui dit il
y a une revue indépendante votre fact
checker peuvent regarder qui s'appelle
linéaire c'est un mensuel un mensuel qui
chaque année fait une analyse qui va
chercher des bilans de nos entreprises
et qui fait un comparatif avec les
concurrents d'ailleurs on ce résultat
ils ont montré que ça a même baissé je
crois qu'on est à 194 % dans l'étude de
fin d'année dernière pour nous c'est le
minimum on pourra pas descendre en
dessous de ça parce que on a plein
d'obligations 1,94 qui reste ça nous
permet juste
d'investir de remettre ce qu'il faut
dans l'entreprise pour se développer les
technologies dont on a parlé avant le
photovoltaïque et c'est bien et je ne
m'en plains pas du tout qu'on nous
oblige à mettre sur les parkings et
cetera mais si vous allez voir le
banquier sans résultat ben aucune
entreprise ne fonctionne quoi donc il
faut faire un peu de résultat et 2 %
c'est le c'est le minimum on parlait des
bouteilles de soda et on parlait des
pommes des œufs et du lait euh est-ce
que c'est plus facile
de de négocier sa marge avec des petits
producteurs contre des petits
producteurs que face à la grande
entreprise de soda c'est-à-dire que même
avec votre force de frappe vous allez
voir la la grande entreprise de soda ils
vont faire écoute Dominique tu es bien
gentil mais c'est tel prix et c'est tout
donc vous êtes obligés de gratter
ailleurs non mais c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est ce système
de péréquation donc concrètement le plus
petit producteur qui vient nous voir
directement au magasin un fromager un
charcutier un biscuitier mais je vais
vous dire un truc on discute même pas
son prix on ne le discute pas on accepte
son prix c'est une petite TP petite PME
locale je veux dire on a envie d'avoir
ces produits on ne discute pas il me dit
voilà mon mon mon produit c'est c'est t
etant on l'accepte et et on ne discute
pas il vous montre en toute transparence
ses coups ses marges comment il bosse
pas forcément et on le à ce niveau-là on
ne le demande même pas mais voilà plus
l'entreprise après grande forte et
puissante plus on va négocier bien sûr
et voire même de manière intraitable
avec les multinationales même
intraitable avec les multinationales
mais mais mais prenons un chiffre le
chiffre d'affaires aujourd'hui de
Système U global est à peine supérieur
et un peu supérieur au résultats nets de
nestley donc moi face à une
multinationale comme ça 4e acteur du
marché français je ne pèse rien je ne
pèse rien et donc comment on fait et là
c'est un grand sujet de notre métier
actuellement nous on a par exemple
décidé chez u que face à ces 40
puisqu'ils sont 40 très puissants très
grand essentiellement
étranger on a décidé de s'allier avec
des confrères européens on a dit euh on
a dit on on n'y arrive pas nous tout
seul ils sont très puissants ils ont une
vision très eux-mêmes
arbitre en France on va vendre à ce
prix-là en Allemagne on va vendre à ce
prix-là et ce et Cera et cetera et donc
nous face à ces gens-là ben on s'est
allié avec des gens comme Edeka en
Allemagne elunga en Italie jéronimo
Martines au Portugal ikca en Suède on
mène au volume enem pour acheter du coca
du truc et cetera et et ça c'est super
important mais ça n'est pas compris en
France ça c'est sujet très intéressant
c'est pas compris ce sujet est encore
une fois caricaturer on nous dit oui
mais vous faites ça pour des des
tournées je ne sais pas quoi gagner de
l'argent mais pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout on le fait parce qu'on est
trop petit nous tout seul en France on
le fait pour avoir au bout du compte le
bon prix pour le consommateur en France
et on le fait pas pour autre chose ce
n'est ni une question de fiscalité qu'on
cherche à optimiser pas du tout on pieie
notre fiscalité en France et c'est pas
le sujet de gagner de l'argent pas du
tout c'est acheter le bon prix pour
avoir le bon prix pour le consommateur
français et là on mène une vraie
bataille de lobbying actuellement pour
faire progresser cette idée qui n'est
pas comprise en France et j'illustre
j'illustre par une donnée européenne
Eurostat
Eurostat de mémoire quand un panier de
produits alimentaires vaut 100 en
moyenne en Europe il vaut 102 € en
Allemagne il vaut moins de 100 € en
Espagne au
Portugal il vaut 115 € en France est-ce
que c'est normal moi nous on considère
chez u que c'est pas normal et donc on
essaie de de trouver des solutions de
s'organiser pour être plus fort
uniquement face aux 40 plus grandes et
et d'obtenir le bon prix pour nos
clients et et après avec les PME on a
des discussions pleines de discernement
plus constructive et cetera et on essaie
de faire la part des choses et si le
charcutier vient nous voir en disant ben
voilà moi mon électricité elle parce que
c'est arrivé ça me coûte trois fois plus
cher cette année mais on va le prendre
en compte quoi on va le prendre en
compte dans la discussion et on va
accepter son prix à la hausse voilà vous
les voyez comment les prix à venir là
nous nous raconte un petit peu une douce
musique on est arrivé sur un plateau qui
ralentit que ça ralentit pas que ça va
descendre Bruno Le Maire l'inflation il
est il a quel chiffre parce que je vois
un canard ça doit tu je demande à me
faire fact checker ça doit être UFC Que
Choisir dit
les vrais chiffres de l'inflation Bruno
Le Maire il a les faux
chiffres il est dans un autre
monde non Bruno Le Maire par rapport à
la consommation n'est pas dans un autre
monde moi je moi je le côtoie depuis
particulièrement la crise du covid
euh c'est franchement un ministre qui
euh a toujours eu au moins euh comment
dire une sensibilité par rapport au
consommateurs et qu' essayer de trouver
une des solutions par rapport au
consommateurs des solutions
symptomatiques c'est est-ce que vous
l'avez senti un petit peu anticiper les
choses quand même ministre de l'Économie
la guerre économique l'ignement
économqueouè après d'accord après on
peut dire on peut dire que c'était
parfois des solutions conjoncturelles
peut-être à à des situations et cetera
et que une solution plus pérenne serait
d'attaquer le déficit public de la
France de trouver des économies pour que
le système coûte moins cher et cetera
oui on pourrait dire ça mais c'est c'est
je je redis à court terme un ministre
qui a toujours eu avec nous dans le
dialogue collectif qu'on a pu avoir avec
lui une attention pour les Français une
sensibilité à la consommation ce que
d'autres personnes parfois non'ont pas
je dois reconnaître lesquel ah ben je je
je je croise d'autres comment dire
personnalités publiques qui sont parfois
coupés des réalités de la province et et
et ça c'est peut-être la grande leçon
que je tire de l'année moi 2023 dans un
peu comment
dire les les dialogues que je peux avoir
il faut être vigilant à ce qu'il a pas
d'écart entre le centre de décision à
Paris dans plein de domaines et la
réalité de ce que gens les gens vivent
en province voilà il faut que les deux
restent connectés et et
que les difficulté de vivre la
souffrance de certains Français parce
qu'on pourrait rentrer dans le détail de
ça aussi je vous en prie mais derrière
cette inflation pour moi aujourd'hui
plus de 2 tiers des Français ont changé
de comportement et là je dirais toutes
les études vont vont dans dans ce sens 2
tiers des Français ont impacté alors le
tiers du haut un peu le tiers du bas
beaucoup leur comportement ça va jusqu'à
1/ers des Français qui sont ce qu'on
appelle en précarité
alimentaire les étudiants y compris des
étudiants mais 16 % des Français ne
mangent pas à leur fin ne mangent pas à
leur fin et ça il faut quand même le
redire ça ce sont des chiffres je trouve
qui ne sortent pas
assez comment dire dans le débat public
dans la discussion et cetera
pratiquement 15/ ce de la population
française pratiquement 15e au 21e siècle
siècle ne mange pas à sa fin donc ça ce
sont des chiffres extrêmement frappants
mais quand je dis les gens ont changé de
comportement énormément de familles
aujourd'hui nous disent mais moi pour
faire des économies je j'ai je saute
quelque chose dans mon repas avant je
faisais entrée plat fromage dessert
aujourd'hui je fais un plat et un
dessert j'ai arrêté le fromage j'ai
arrêté l'entrée je mange plus qu'une
seule fois par jour et et et et au pire
je ne mange plus qu'une seule fois par
jour mais ça c'est une réalité
de la France d'aujourd'hui c'est une
réalité de la France d'aujourd'hui qui
pour moi
malheureusement n'émerge pas n'émerge
pas suffisamment et donc moi mon boulot
aussi c'est c'est au maximum
d'accompagner ces Français et de trouver
des des solution et et si
u sort parmi les gagnants de l'année
dernière c'est parce qu'il se rendent
compte que je pense qu'on a fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour les accompagner
et que nos prix sont extrêmement
compétitifs sur le marché les étudiants
vous les
voyez les étudiants on les voit
particulièrement mes collègues qui sont
en ville il nous Arve
régulièrement de contribuer à des
associations d'aide alimentaire comment
les banques alimentaires on a un
partenariat privilégié avec la Banque
alimentaire de deux façons soit c'est le
magasin qui donne particulièrement
pendant les collectes mais on a un
contrat même tête groupe ou par exemple
dans nos entrepôts on a aussi des
produits qui arrivent à date courte et
cetera on les donne à la banque
alimentaire en quantité importante et et
la Banque Alimentaire ben elle alimente
aussi des des étudiants mais onê parfois
d'autres association mais les demandes
n'ont jamais été aussi fortes que ces
derniers temps et et la Banque
Alimentaire les restos du cœur ont pris
la parole publiquement pour dire que
jamais autant il n'avait autant de
demandeurs que parfois ils n'ont même
pas pu accepter tous les demandeurs donc
ça c'est c'est une réalité sur sur le
terrain bien évidemment quelle est la la
coulisse de tout ça ça c'est que face
aux dépenses contraintes dans votre
budget les dépenses contraintes c'est le
carburant vous êtes obligé vous avez une
voiture vos abonnements votre logement
vous payez un loyer ça plutôtug Assur
les assurances qui ont augmenté tout ça
c'est les mutuels la complémentaire
santé tout ça c'est contraint vous ne
pouvez pas vous vous vous le subissez il
y a un poste que vous pouvez encore
maîtriser un peu c'est l'alimentaire et
donc celui-là vous le restraignez jamais
autant enfin de ma carrière
professionnelle et je pense depuis très
longtemps les Français n'ont autant
arbitré leur budget alimentaire c'est
que le début je pense que c'est que le
début et je pense même moi j'ai une
alerte c'est que je pense même qu'à
terme si ça dure ça peut avir des
conséquences sur la santé quand vous
mangez moins de fruits et légumes un des
arbitrages qui est fait c'est moins de
fruits et légumes moins de produits
frais mais plus peut-être de produits un
peu moins chers et cetera et moins frais
ça peut avoir un impact à terme sur la
santé donc faut qu'on fasse attention
vous connaissez le proverbe des
grands-parents quand il n'y a plus de
foin dans les rateliers les chevaux se
battent vous sentez ça venir une une
révolte non un peu un peu un
peu un peu 1789 quand les gens
commencaient à avir un peu la dalle
excusez-moi j'ai j'ai un petit rhume je
prends régulièrement le train et le et
le train de ce lundi matin il y avait
pas de chauffage donc vous n avez pas
ramené des miasmes d'Alsace non non non
non c'est vraiment juste un petit coup
de froid lié à ce train on embrasse
l'Alsace pendant que vous vous
mouchez on embrasse leur patrimoine
gastronomique on les embrasse les
Alsaciens les als je n'ai pas de signe
par contre tu veux pas tu veux parler un
message à la famille
non on a un alsacien ici ouioui on a un
alsacien je j'avais par contre des
signes de l'émergence des gilets jaunes
je peux je vous raconte cette anecdote
vous adorez les anecdote nous sommes on
adore les anecdotes de terrain de
terrain et celle-là en est une de
terrain je suis élu président de systamu
en mai 2018 un mois plus tard au mois de
juin 2018 j'ai ma première mon premier
rendez-vous de la profession au
ministère de l'Économie à Bercy avec
Bruno
leemire la première d'E longue série je
ne sais plus quel était le thème du jour
on était avant covid c'était une réunion
sectorielle à la fin donc petit bleu de
service à l'époque j'étais je débarquais
j'étais pas connu et cetera donc les les
barons du métier Michel éedouard Leclerc
Jean-Charles naori étit en face du
ministre et puis et puis les petits
nouveaux étaient sur les côtés je je me
souviendrais toujours de ça après ça
évolué avec le temps et à la fin le
ministre demande à à à l'Assemblée
messieurs voilà la Réunion est terminée
avez-vous quelque chose à dire et moi je
me dis mais est-ce que est-ce que je
saisis la parole parce que j'avais
quelque chose à dire et et et et je
venais avec ça il y av votre nom sur la
table oui il y a il y a un petit carton
pour que le ministre puisse s'adresser à
vous pour que le ministre puisse savoir
et je lève la main et je dis oui
monsieur le ministre moi j'ai quelque
chose ah bon de quoi
s'agit-il vous avez relevé deux fois les
taxes sur le carburant une première fois
au 1er janvier 2017 ça on l'oublie mais
il y avait une première phase
là puis au 1er janvier 2018 et à partir
du printemps et particulièrement là au
mois de mai au mois de juin on
commençait à sentir nous sur le terrain
dans nos stations service on a
énormément de ça on a plus de 800
stations service
euh vraiment un mécontentement une
grogne autour de ce prix du carburant
qui avait augmenté avec les taxes et
donc je dis monsieur le ministre S se
passe quelque chose autour du prix du
carburant
euh c'est répétitif c'est insistant il
faut en prendre note je vois les
conseillers à côté du ministre prendre
des notes et cetera et cette petite
alerte qui valait ce qu'elle valait et
je ne savais pas ce qu'elle allait
devenir mais c'était euh on va dire 3 4
mois avant l'émergence des gilets jaunes
et donc on l'avait dans notre métier
dans notre profession dans notre
regroupement en tout cas on l'avait
senti venir et donc est-ce que je sens
quelque chose aujourd'hui ma réponse est
non mais j'ai envie de vous dire
que c'est une réponse d'ALS ou d' vernia
ça non mais c'est une réponse très
précise alsacienne oui ou peut-être au
vergotte non alsacien moi je suis
alsacien on a vécu le covid entre temps
le
covid moi je pense a changé beaucoup de
choses peut-être même inconsciemment
dans la tête des gens du jour au
lendemain les gens ont accepté des
contraintes incroyables ont suivi
pendant des mois un confinement puis un
arrêt de confinement puis un
reconfinement des des plein
d'obligations de toutes sortes pour se
déplacer et cetera et j'ai l'impression
que ça mis une sorte un peu de chape
sur sur les gens et que j'ai
l'impression chap c'est quoi une chape
c'est une résignation
c'est une catatonie émotionnelle
qu'est-ce que c'est cette chape c'est
c'est c'est une espèce de déjà de de de
de de on suit les règles on suit les
règles parce que vous êtes en Alsace euh
oui oui peut-être mais de de de
résignation de bah c'est comme ça et on
peut on peut rien faire et et et parfois
j'ai l'impression que par rapport aux
difficultés actuelles mais il y a un peu
de ça quoi c'est-à-dire que bah c'est
comme ça et cetera et on peut on peut on
peut rien faire et et et et on et on vit
avec ma question c'est c'est jusqu'à
quand mais ça j'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas la
réponse et encore une fois j'ai pas de
signe mais je sais je dis simplement que
pour un certain nombre de Français c'est
clair que c'est très difficile en ce
moment avec ce sentiment en plus de de
quoi il fait l'avenir quoi combien de
fois quand on m'arrête les gens qui
m'ont arrêté mais je me souviens de
c'était vraiment à Noël une retra une
retraitée une retraitée ça c'est un
autre public est qui est en difficulté
parce que eux leur retraite alors elle a
un peu augmenté mais pas beaucoup alors
que toute leur charge augmente donc ça
pince ça pince très fort cette dame
avait vécu de mémoire une très belle
carrière dans l'éducation nationale elle
me dit je n'y arrive plus je n'y arrive
plus et mon problème elle me disait une
dame d'un certain âge c'est presque pas
moi mais c'est mes enfants et mes petits
enfants alors ça ça ça vient constamment
dans la discussion c'est quoi l'avenir
de nos enfants et de nos petits-enfants
et et et et ça c'est quand même la
question qui revient de manière majeure
actuellement très vite quand tu discutes
avec les gens la question de l'avenir
vous vous vous faites pas de livraision
de fiel vous non pas comme le on le on
le fait avec des partenaires
euh ça peut nous arriver pourquoi cette
cette anecdote avec la retraitée me fait
penser une une anecdote que mon livreur
de foul me racontait sur les veuves avec
des pensions de reversion toutes petite
euh euh être obligé de se cô entre
petite vieilles de la rue pour se faire
livrer 500 L et venir carrément
pratiquement avec le jerican pour
pouvoir avoir de l'eau chaude et les
grand-mères chauffer à 10 degrés oui
mais alors je vous raconte une autre
anecdote je revient à mon chef boucher
Thierry dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure et mon livreur me disait ça me
fait tellement mal au cœur que j'ai
envie de monter en haut de la citerne
pour contourner le le le le compteur
pour le donner un sa de fou mais je peux
pas mais ça lui briser le cœur mais bien
sûr que ça brise le cœur mais moi j'ai
une autre anecdote qui brise le cœur
dans mon magasin toujours en Alsace un
couple de retraité très connu de de mon
équipe des clients habituel un jour
savez il y a il y a quelques personnes
dans le magasin où souvent les gens se
livrent les hôesses de caisse c'est
formidable c'est souvent d'ailleurs la
seule personne à qui tu parles les gens
se livrent parfois l'âche des anecdotes
quand ils se connaissent et les bouché
aussi quand tu vas discuter avec ton
boucher qui a un peu de temps tu dis tu
te livres un peu les bouchers savent
énormément de choses et benur aussi mais
les coiffeurs aussi absolument mais tout
ça c'est des professions hyper
importantes hyper importantes les taxi
aussi ah bah alors les taxi ça je le
sais puisque ça m'arrive à Paris de
prendre des taxis et donc ce couple
arrive c'était au début de
l'hiver au bord des larmes avec le
boucher en disant mais cet hiver on on
ne sait pas comment on va payer le
chauffage on ne sait pas comment on va
payer le chauffage et il était venu me
voir ensuite le boucher en disant mais
je suis bouleversé qu'est-ce que je fais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire c'est pas
possible je pensais pas que ces gens-là
auraient des difficultés donc c'est ce
type de témoignage qu'on a dans nos
magasins et qui qui nous prennent au
tripes et qui me font vous dire à vous
que c'est pour ça aussi que j'aime ce
métier j'aime ce métier parce qu'on est
au cœur de la vie des gens qu'on est au
cœur de de de de cette vie des français
qu'on suit ça et que et qu'après moi
j'essaie
voilà au rôle qui est le mien B de
remonter ces infos et de mener quelques
quelques batailles sur certains
sujets question Internet d'un d'un
français au
Canada le plus gros problème dans les
prix c'est clairement le transport le
pétrole de point si vous défendez tant
les circuits courts c'est aussi à votre
avantage non
bien sûr moins de distance des prix
stables en rayon point d'inrogation
alors ok fruit café chocolat ça pose des
problèmes mais oui alors Système U on
est une coopérative de commerçants
indépendant chaque patron est libre de
s'approvisionner où il veut en gros à 80
% il commande sa marchandise à notre
centrale d'achat les grandes marques les
produits et à 20 % et parfois dans
certains magasins ça monte à 30 % il
s'approvisionne en local de la viande
des fruits et légumes en local mais bien
sûr ça c'est gagnant c'est d'autant plus
gagnant demain si on mesure les impact
davantage sauf que sauf que ça ne ça ne
couvre pas l'ensemble de l'offre
nécessaire à un panier de course
habituel des clients et donc et
donc il faut mixer les deux quoi et et
nous on est vraiment une enseigne on
essaie de mixer les deux une grande part
de cette appro locale de tout ce qu'on
peu et on cherche beaucoup et en
permanence et ça s'est d'ailleurs étoffé
pendant le
covid et après ben les gens pour des
couches pour des des des sodas et cetera
il y a il y a des grandes marques et nos
produits qui sont nécessaires donc faut
mixer les deux pour trouver le bon
équilibre revenons à la géopolitique
l'anticipation des crises pour protéger
le business et protéger le consommateur
ou protéger son propre business pour
éviter de se faire acheter par des
concurrents agressifs avec plus de
trésoreries comment vous
sentez la mer Rouge qui se fait un peu
canardé par les outils en répercussion
du conflit Israël aupalestinien comment
vous sentez le fait que les Iraniens ont
été cartonnés les Pakistanais que les
Iraniens s'il couent TR qu bateaux en
face de chez eux il y a plus de
pétrolier qui passe comment vous sentez
l'émergence pas l'émergence mais le
retour de Trump comment vous sentez le
conflit ukrainien quelle répercussion ça
peut avoir sur votre business mais vous
voilà vous
résumez toutes les pistes d'incertitude
qui font que nous sommes plus que jamais
dans un monde instable et et et encore
une fois je décrivais tout à l'heure un
monde de la grande distribution très
stable pendant 40 ans et ben nous notre
métier ne l'est plus mais comme le
contexte politique et international ne
l'est plus et l'ensemble des sujets que
vous venez de décrire nous nous
préoccupe la mer Rouge dont où la
circulation est perturbée actuellement
est en train de nous perturber nous
concrètement moi j'ai des magasins à
Madagascar à la Réunion à l'île Maurice
pas à Mayotte à Mayot on y travaille on
y travaille on est en train de
travailler à Mayotte on aimerait bien
arriver à Mayotte et je pense qu'on a
des belles pistes mais on yy est pas
encore paf on peut plus passer par la
mer Rouge insécurité on est obligé
passer par le Cap de Bonne Espérance
c'est le doublement du temps et donc un
prix beaucoup plus cher et pratiquement
le triplement du prix c'est ça et le
triplement du prix mais ça c'est
terrible il combien le contenur ces
10000 là 10000 dollars non c'est plus
10000 c'était 10000 au cœur de la crise
il est redescendu à 1500 2000 dollars
mais là dès qu'il y a une incertitude de
nouveau PAF il remonte et comme il y a
très peu d'opérateurs capables de
transporter des conteners euh d'un bout
de à l'autre du monde et
particulièrement sur des lignes qui sont
parfois pas rentables comme ces petites
îles-là paf le prix vient de nouveau
d'augmenter donc le la moindre
incertitude perturbe euh perturbe et
donc là on cherche des solutions mais
bon des solutions là en l'occurrence on
a pas 5 ans c'est Cap de Bonne Espérance
dans toute la liste que vous venez de
faire moi il y a quelque chose qui me
préoccupe encore plus que vous n'avez
pas cité le réchauffement climatique non
la situation de l'Allemagne il a
extraordinaire oui bah oui mais je suis
au bord à côté de la frontière allemande
l'Allemagne c'était jusqu'à présent le
moteur économique de l'Europe et et le
moteur ça consomme
quoi ça consomme de l'énergie pas cher
et et l'énergie euh voilà on voit on
découvre aujourd'hui on découvre les
limites de ce qu'a été le modèle
allemand pendant des années vous vous
rendez compte de cette phrase là on
découvre ouvre mais oui avec mais oui le
le pic énergétique les relations avec
les Russes la guerre économique on
découvre nous je suis désolé mais nous
on voit ça ça fait 15 ans qu'on fait de
la prospective non mais bien sûr on les
regarde comme si c'était des
aurries je suis d'accord on découvre le
grand public découvre on savait bien
quand on regardait en détail que le
modèle pourrait à un moment ou un autre
craquer et qu' suffisait d'une étincelle
pour craquer il y a une étincelle grave
qui qui a fait dérailler le truc mais on
savait on déc mais on découvre euh au au
sens large je veux dire et et donc ça ça
m'inquiète parce que euh l'Allemagne se
cherche actuellement plus hein que que
ça tout se dérègle c'était parfaitement
réglé sur mais sur des bases voilà qui
étai pas bonnes et ça ça ça me préoccupe
beaucoup ensuite euh ça ça me préoccupe
parce que parce que ben si s'il y a
moins d'échanges économiques et et si et
si cette puissance économique n'est pas
en forme ça aura un impact sur tout
l'Europe l'élection aux États-Unis aura
aura des impacts euh très clair
également si demain c'est c'est Trump
qui est élu aux États-Unis euh alors je
suis pas un spécialiste de toutes de de
toutes ces questionsl mais on peut très
bien imaginer qu'il arrête par exemple
certain nombre d'aide à l'Europe qui
sera obligé de se prendre en charge
elle-même et qui va renchérir renchérir
nos coups donc oui il y a plein de
sujets cette année qui auront des
impacts sur nos vies au bout du compte
c'est
clair est-ce que chez vous on jette de
la
nourriture c'est-à-dire est-ce que on a
vu je sais pas si ça perdure toujours
mais ça nous avait profondément choqué
au cul des supermarchés les grand grande
poubelle avec des gars qui balançaient
des bidons d'eau de Javel dessus pour
éviter que les gens aillent c'est une
catastrophe ça ça ne se fait pas plus
euh dans la l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire alors c'est un chiffre euh
fond alors
FAO FAO c'est
bon laisse pédaler ouais ouais c'est
quoi c'est les prix ont baissé de 13 %
là non non non non ce que je vais vous
dire c'est que 1/ers de ce qui qui est
produit en alimentation dans le monde
est jeté
euh chiffre FAO organisation
internationale de l'alimentation faud
trouver la traduction exacte pardon mais
j'ai j'ai plus la
traduction ce tiers il est il est les
chiffres sont intéressants il il il est
comment dire détruit à à différents
moment il est détruit en partie à la
production même en partie dans le champ
en partie chez le transformateur
industriel en parti euh comment dire
ensuite dans nos magasins de mémoire le
chiffre que j'ai moi en tête c'est 16 %
euh de de gaspillage de destruction au
niveau des magasins mais après il est
détruit dans la restauration et je crois
que c'est à 19 % dans le frigo des
consommateurs à 19 % ce qui est gaspillé
jeté dans le frigo et même supérieur à
ce qui est gaspillé jeté en proportion
chez nous donc pour moi c'est un sujet
majeur on ne peut plus accepter qu'un
tiers de ce qui est produit dans le
monde soit jeté parce que produit dans
le monde ça veut dire on a utilisé de
l'eau on a fait travailler des gens
transpirer c'est inacceptable on trer du
pétrole on a utilisé du du pétrole des
énergies fossiles tout ce que vous
voulez du gaz pour le produire c'est
inacceptable donc on marche sur la tête
et ça faut absolument le travailler donc
depuis quelques années il y a une
mobilisation générale sur ce sujet à
notre du Maillon euh et donc ça se
traduit par quoi ben en plus c'est
gagnant pour tout le monde c'est les
fameux bacs antigaspie à la fin du
circuit dans un magasin les dates qui
arrivent à échéance sont extraites des
rayons de base et vendus à prix cassé
dans les bas qutigaspille - 30 - 40 %
parce qu'il y a plus qu'un ou de jours
de date ça c'est un succès considérable
parce que un c'est des produits qu'on
gaspie pas et deux c'est du pouvoir
d'achat pour pour les français donc ça
ça marche terriblement
ensuite pourquoi vous dites
terriblement mais parce que pourquoi je
dis terriblement parce que c'est
terrible au bout du compte je veux dire
euh que quand on ouvre les portes mais
j'ai plein de témoignages dans ce sens
on prépare le magasin souvent à partir
de 5h du matin les équipes sont là 5h du
matin travaillent ce bac an il gaspie il
est rempli avant l'ouverture du magasin
en général en province à 8h30 9h à 8h30
à l'ouverture des portes il y a des gens
qui se précipitent à ce bac
antigaspi pour faire leurs achats du
jour parce qu'ils vont économiser 40 50
% du prix normal ils vont pouvoir le
congeler et ils ont raison ce sont des
bonnes affaires ça il y a 5 ans en
arrière on avait pas ce phénomène donc
quelque part c'est terrible quoi voilà
on on répond on répond à plein de choses
mais il faudrait qu'on y réponde
autrement quoi faudrait qu'on y réponde
autrement pour ça que M sorti le mot
terrible première étape de comment on
traite les choses deuxième étape on fait
encore des dons on en a déjà parlé tout
à l'heure mais quand il reste des
produits on fait des dons et puis et
puis le le reste part en méthanisation
beaucoup en ce qu'on appelle des
biodéchets c'està direire qu'on a des
prestataires parfois des paysans qui
utilisent cette matière ça peut être du
pain ça peut être des légumes et cetera
pour produire de l'énergie donc on n'est
pas parfait bien
sûr on essaie de de réduire ça de
limiter ça et et de faire que ce soit
réutilisé et que ça serve le mieux
possible ça existe plus les les ultra
ultra discounterur où il y avait en
rayon ces dates de péremption si il y a
des petites chaînes qui existent qui
récupèrent des lots chez des industriels
parfois chez d'autres commerçants pour
écouler des produits c'est une solution
mais ça n'a pas pris une ampleur non
plus considérable parce que la
distribution classique s'est mise à
faire ces offres là aussi ça vous fait
peur l'arrivée de certains ultra ultra
ultra discompteur façon allemande en
France peur non moi j'ai pas l'habitude
d'avoir peur estce que vous êtes alacien
c'est pour ça j'ai pas l'habitude
d'avoir peur moi je suis un combattant
je veux dire on est là pour se battre on
a des concurrents et on on on fait ce
qu'il faut pour les affronter mais je
prends ça très au sérieux et je prends
ça très au sérieux pourquoi
parce que ça n'est pas pris ce phénomène
n'est pas pris à sa juste
importance par un certain nombre
d'acteurs euh on voit les acteurs
classiques français et on leur impose
des lois à nous beaucoup et et et et
d'un seul coup moi j'explique mais
Messieurs donc là je pense au
parlementairire par exemple et Messieurs
mais vous connaissez Lidl aldiy action
dit ben non on connaît pas bien et
cetera mais ça ce sont des chaînes
étrangère euh une puissance
internationale souvent présente dans de
nombreux pays du monde qui ont une
capacité d'achat internationale à un
niveau européen voire mondial par
exemple pour Lidl qui sont très
puissants et qui défèent en France avec
des produits achetés au niveau
international et et donc des prix
parfois compétitif sur certains sujets
et nous on aurait en contrepartie pas le
droit
de s'unir comme je vous le décrivais
tout à l'heure au niveau européen par
exemple pour acheter ensemble et faire
face à cette nouvelle concurrence mais
c'est absurde et donc quand on nous dit
non non mais vous distributeur
traditionnel français vous ne pouvez pas
aller vous organiser c'est c'est c'est
incompréhensible et donc moi par exemple
dans mon lobbying pour faire évoluer les
choses je me bat beaucoup pour ce genre
de de de question question internet que
je découvre avec vous bon bons soir que
pensez-vous de la situation actuelle des
agriculteurs des éleveurs que
pensez-vous des répercussions de la
quête d'un prix bas pour le consommateur
quel rôle jouez-vous quel rôle
jouez-vous dans l'essort des
exploitations industrielles seul
compétitive et mise en avant dans vos
structures face à cette course en avant
de la baisse des prix et autres lié à la
compétition européenne comment soutenir
nos
agriculteurs en appliquant la loi
qui est laquelle depuis quelques années
nous travaillons sous le couvert de loi
qui s'appelle égalimain égalim 2 égalim
3 ou la égalim 3 c'est aussi une loi qui
est appelée la loi décroosaill du nom du
parlementaire qui l'a mise au point
qu'il a
proposé ces lois-là
elles que nous avons soutenu chez depuis
le début avait pour objectif quoi
pendant toutes les années de
distribution classique dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure et effectivement il y a
eu une course au prix bas que je
reconnais et auquel u a aussi participé
mais pas en tant que leader du marché il
un leader du marché particulièrement ça
ça marche pas comme argument ça bah
Leclerc parlons de Lecler de ça marche
pas com il faut jamais se comparer entre
guillemets au dernier de la classe ou
celui qui a le d'accord mais bon il y a
une course au prix bas du marché au
global pour arrêter cette course à un
moment qui qui qui était sans fin et est
contreproductive et mettant à risque
notre souveraineté
alimentaire on a soutenu la mise en
place de la loi égalim pour apporter des
limites sur ce marché et concrètement la
dernière version de la loi nous nous
oblige à faire quoi la part de matières
premières agrices dans la discussion est
sanctuarisée à partir du moment où
l'industriel vient nous voir en nous
disant voilà là-dedans il y a tant et
tant de blé acheté à ce niveau et cetera
on a plus le droit de le
discuter sur les années 2000 euh 22 21
ça fait progresser en général le revenu
agricole et je me souviens moi chaque
année je vais au salon de l'agriculture
au dernier Salon de l'agriculture il y
avait plus tellement de sujets de
rémunération comment dire de des des
agriculteurs grâce à l'impact positif de
cette loi qui n'a pas tout réglé je m'
m'empresse de le dire mais qui a
amélioré des choses particulièrement
dans le lait par exemple et dans un
certain nombre de matières et donc il y
a eu un progrès grâce à ça un exemple
pour répondre à la question qui est
posée deuxième exemple j'ai signé la
semaine dernière au nom de Système U un
contrat tripartite pour la fabrication
du lait bio à la marque u une bouteille
1 litre de lait bio autour de la table
la coopérative de producteur BioLit 1200
fermes en France de producteurs de lait
bio tous exemplaires dans des cahiers
des charges précis heureux de de
produire ce lait là un transformateur
c'est celui qui nous met le lait en
bouteille il est aussi là et nous pour
la vente on a signé à 3 un contrat de 5
ans un contrat de 5 ans dans lequel il
est écrit noir sur blanc j'ai reli relu
personnellement le contrat nous
recherchons un prix juste pour le
producteur basé sur son coût de produit
et c'est ça qu'on a signé et ce prix on
le revoit chaque année en fonction de
ses coûts de production mais quelle est
la différence entre le premier cas et le
deuxè dans le deuxème cas c'est la
marque u on n'est pas soumis au régime
de de contractualisation comme les
grandes marques on est dans un régime
qui est libre on discute avec les gens
toute l'année on peut signer des
contrats de 5 ans qui sont gagnants pour
tout le monde sur les grandes marques
c'est différent on doit négocier en ce
moment même là cette année donc entre le
1er novembre et le 31
janvier et le prix doit s'appliquer
toute l'année c'est très strict et bon
voilà qui a un système qui est
complètement dépassé plus adapté et et
pour les marques distributeurs mais nous
et les autres on peut discuter toute
l'année tranquillement mettre des beaux
contrats et ça c'est gagnant pour tout
le monde donc voilà ce qu'essaie de
faire eu et donc derrière ça moi je
plaide pour la révision du système de
négociation dans la grande distribution
nous permettre de discuter tout au long
de l'année avec l'ensemble des
producteurs pour répercuter au plus vite
les variations de matières premières
qu'elles soi à la hausse si c'est à la
hausse ben c'est gagnant pour le
producteur si c'est à la baisse c'est
gagnant pour le consommateur et et ça
c'est pas gagné je me bats pour ça les
autres aussi se battent pour ça leclire
il doit se battre pour ça aussi non mais
j'étais le premier à me battre pour ça
et Michel Édouard que j'adore
aujourd'hui il suit sur ce sujet-là
c'est bien question internet il y a-t-il
une guaygerre entre les industriels
producteurs et les distributeurs pour
savoir qui doit assumer la
responsabilité de l'inflation est-ce que
les distributeurs ne se sentent pas
menacer au point de devoir prendre la
parole dans les médias pour essayer de
faire porter la responsabilité de cette
inflation aux industriels et
producteurs réponse très précise
là-dessus qu'est-ce que je dis je dis
dit que quand il y a une situation
inflationniste telle que nous la vivons
actuellement qui est dramatique encore
une fois on l'a illustré pour de
nombreux Français nous devons nous nous
nous répartir la charge de
l'accompagnement des Français euh une
part nous une part l'industriel et
cetera et moi mon propos est de dire je
pense que dans cette phase
inflationniste nous avons fait des
efforts alors on pourra nous dire que
oui mais vous en navez pas fait assez
moi j'ai un critère qui me dit qu'on a
fait des efforts c'est que le résultat
final de mon groupe et de mes
entreprises il baissent il baissent
pourquoi parce qu'on a mis en place
beaucoup d'actions pour accompagner les
Français c'est un critère très précis
financier tout simple qui démontre que
parce qu'on a mis plus de promotions en
place parce qu'on a baissé nos prix on a
un peu moins de résultats on a joué
notre part par contre je considère et
j'assume j'assume mon propos je pense
qu'un certain nombre de très grand
industriels particulièrement
multinationales n'ont pas assez joué le
jeu et ont profité de cette période
d'inflation pour conforter leur marge
incontestablement incontestablement
quand l'année dernière on vient nous
voir avec une demande de hausse de plus
de 10 % sur un produit de base genre les
gâteaux ça ok les biscuits les biscuits
qu'on revient nou voir cette année alors
que le blé est fortement en baisse avec
une nouvelle osse de 8 % on ne le
comprend pas si ce n'est pour une seule
raison qui est que derrière ces ces
demandes de hausse il y a aussi
l'obligation de rémunérer des
actionnaires internationaux qui ont une
attente de rentabilité et qui et qui
sont loin est-ce que vous m'autorisez à
faire l'avocat du diable
allez-y ces grandes multinationales qui
sont pas devenu
multinationales en cherchant
des champignons sous les pieds des
chevaux ils ont ils ont bossé pour ça
c'est des grands groupes qui ont accès à
des grandes cellules de prospective de
guerre économique de renseignement
économique ils se disent bon alors la
situation actuelle c'est ça ça ça ça les
anticipations c'est ça ça ça ça pour
racheter qui pour éviter de se faire
racheter avec une OP agressive il faut
qu'on chope du pognon pour être plus
fort certes on va rémunérer nos
actionnaires et ainsi de suite mais
est-ce que vous sentez pas en
fait en fait vous comprenez pas parce
que vous êtes plus petit est-ce que
est-ce que vous comprenez pas le jeu de
la guerre économique c'estd qu'il
demandent des augmentations parce qu'ils
anticipent mieux que vous que la
situation dégénère avec
l'approvisionnement énergétique ou de de
choses comme ça et qui préfèr
maintenant faire du
gras pour les jours difficiles qui
arrivent non mais
oui en partie non mais oui c'est quoi ça
vous fait pas du Macron hein on fait je
fais pas du Macron en partie oui
peut-être avec leur vision mondiale leur
vision de l'ensemble des marchés leur
anticipation
euh d'une crise pour leur activité plus
forte et cetera peut-être qu'elles
veulent se renforcer mais on est face à
des puissances incroyable je veux dire
les les les leaders du marché font des
résultats considérables qui pour moi les
mettent d'ors et déjà à l'abri d'un
certain nombre de soubressau quand même
et donc ce que je dis c'est que quand il
y a une crise inflationniste de ce
niveau-là qui met en difficulté tant de
gens et ben à un moment tu contribues tu
participes mais moi je vous le dis et et
là euh je parle avec mes négociateurs
avec les équipes j'ai parfois certains
grands patrons téléphone ce qui me
frappe c'est que ces gens-là souvent
n'ont pas le consommateur en
préoccupation non' pas les difficultés
ils ne sont pas en contact avec les
Français avec les clients comme nous le
sommes ils sont dans leur bullle
financière et d'organisation et donc
leur sujet c'est leur rentabilité et ça
n'est pas le combat comme nous pour le
consommateur combat imparfait on peut
nous faire des reproches aussi mais je
pense qu'on a pris notre part et et
encore une fois je dis ils n'ont pas
pris leur part voilà je je dis juste ça
et et et et donc moi j'entends ce que
vous dites mais je pense que souvent
c'est une expérience de pensée pour pour
les 40 pour les 40 là il y a une
puissance qui est suffisamment là est
solide et et
et qui permet de de de faire quelque
chose à court terme mais ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas
fait question Internet ne ne
défiscalise-t-il pas à travers la Banque
Alimentaire philanthropie ou
opportunisme
fiscal
alors comment dire oui le sujet précis
que on on veut me faire dire là c'est
que on peut
faire transformer ce qu'on donne à la
banque alimentaire sous forme de don et
avoir le reçu qui permet de de
défiscaliser alors certaines entreprises
le font je vais vous dire certaines
entreprises ne l'utilisent même pas donc
il y a pas un sujet de de de d'avantage
fiscal derrière ça il y a un sujet de
ire le gaspillage alimentaire et et de
donner pour éviter que ce soit jeté
perdu et ça c'est totalement annexe et
ça ne représente rien dans le compte
d'exploitation d'un
magasin les caisses automatiques chez
vous il y a ça alors il y a ce qu'on
appelle du du self checkout alors
souvent en français ça s'appelle comment
ouais de des caisses libre service donc
souvent on me dit oui mais vous mettez
ça pour réduire le personnel notre
vision du commerce n'est pas à celle-là
euh la vision de ces caissesl c'est que
je vois par exemple dans mon magasin
j'en ai installé quatre
euh je n'ai pas du tout réduit le nombre
de caissières au contraire j'ai deux
caissières une le matin une l'après-midi
qui SuperV ces quatre caisses j'ai pas
réduit l'effectif par contre c'est un
service pour les gens qui viennent en
panier et qui est très apprécié et par
contre je vais garder mes aôesses de
caisse qui sont là pour aussi discuter
avec les gens que les gens apprécient et
cetera donc il y a pas de sujet de
développer les caisses libre service
pour réduire le le personnel il a des
petites douchettes chez vous des petits
pistolets pour qu'on c'est minoritaire
il y en a dans certains magasins mais
c'est minoritaire il y a de l'analyse de
de vitesse de chemin dans vos magasins
ou pas non pas avec ça non vous aviez
fini la réponse j'avais fini la réponse
ce que je veux dire puisque vous m'avez
interrogé sur la technologie tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas au aujourd'hui de
technologie qui permet de de technologie
FiBL peu coûteuse qui permet de
remplacer les hôè de caisse ça n'existe
pas et donc je pense que les hutesses de
caisses sont encore là pour de longues
années j'espère bien alors il y a des
recherches il y a des tests et cetera
mais nous notre vision c'est que les
hôesses de caisses sont encore là pour
un certain temps on cherche ardemment on
va dans les salons professionnel on va
chercher mais on n' pas trouvé encore la
technologie de demain sur ce sujetl et
et et dans vos supermarchés est-ce qu'il
y a une file dédiée pour chatcher avec
les aute bla BL caiss les bla BL caiss
alors je je alors je crois que bla bla
caisse c'est déposé par quelqu'unfour
ouais donc les les caisses pour discuter
oui c certains de nos magasins l' mis en
place mais bien sû avec son voisin qui
on disc sûr ça c'est né de mémoire en
Écosse et dès que c'était sorti ça a été
repris dans dans de nombreux magasins
mais mais oui les gens adorent discuter
avec leur hôtel de caisse qui
connaissent depuis des années c'est un
vrai un véritable plaisir et
et ça fait partie de la vie de no de nos
magasins nos magasins sont des lieux de
vie quand dans un village de 3000
habitants il y a plus de bistro parce
qu'il y a plein de bistroc conf fermé
parfois il y a scandale ça bah oui c'est
c'est souvent le super une place de
village son bistrou c'est un scandale
c'est un scandale je suis d'accord avec
vous mais c'est un fait pour plein de
raisons et ben souvent le lieu de vie
est devenu le supermarché qui est
critiqué pour d'autres choses mais nous
sommes devenus des moi je dis le
supermarché est devenu au au 21e siècle
le bistro du 20e siècle il y a des gens
qui viennent consommer dans vos
supermarchés pour pas payer qui ouvrent
une bouteille qui se mettent un peu de
shampoing sur la tête ou qui repartent
avec un paquet de gâteau dans la bouche
c'est pas un phénomène c'est pas un
phénomène arriver mais ou qu' gamin
prennent un Brezel ou je sais pas
c'est un épiphénomène question internet
bonsoir pour faire baisser le coût
alimentaire et paliier nos problèmes de
production européenne allons-nous ouvrir
nos frontières au poules ukrainienne à
la viande d'Amérique du Sud et je
complète l'on Nouvelle-Zélande en résumé
abaisser nos standards mais non pas chez
systèmu pas chez systèmeu on a derrière
l'ensemble des questions là sur le
revenu des agriculteur derriè cette
question là de la question de la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France de
s'assurer que demain nous ayons encore
suffisamment de production de volail de
lait et et le lait est en train de
diminuer chaque année il y a ce qu'on
appelle une déprise
laitière il faut qu'on continue à
défendre ça et donc nous on a décidé que
sur les produits à la marque U et de
manière générale par exemple sur la
viande toute la viande fraîche est
française elle est
française sur le le jambon à la marque u
c'est du français le beurre j'ai un
grand confrère actuellement qui a décidé
pour baisser encore toujours plus le
prix de s'approvisionner en plaquette de
beurre de 150 g dans un autre pays
européen chez u on ne le fera pas on on
continuera à proposer une plaquette de
beurre
français payer au juste prix payer au
juste prix dans le cadre d'un contrat
souvent tripartite
alors on a 50 filières comme ça où
souvent les contrats sont
tripartites on ne veut pas partir
là-dedans c'est notre c'est encore une
fois notre marque de fabrique mais c'est
un risque actuellement c'est un vrai
risque on se tient au courant pour le
Salon de l'Agriculture nous on est
invité au salon de l'agriculture par des
agriculteurs de quelques régions
françaises est-ce que ça vous dirait
qu'on se met tous autour d'une table
pour discuter et Bo des cous mais moi
j'ai aucun souci pour discuter évidment
des coups d'abord des coups oui mais
bien sûr ce que je viens de vous
expliquer là je suis très libre et
transparent pour
l'expliquer partout on a 50 filières qui
sont totalement vertueuses on a pour les
grandes marques la loi égalime qui
sanctuarise la part de matières
premières agricoes et on le respecte
mais ça je je l'assume et je suis prêt à
en débattre avec toutes les parties
prenantes que vous voulez et je encore
une fois je vais chaque année au Salon
de l'Agriculture j'en profite pour faire
ma petite pause ouais j'en profite pour
vous
laisser vous drainez les
sinus vous restez combien de temps au
salon de
l'agriculture en général j'y passe j'y
passe de ou 3
jours il y a plein de monde à voir il y
a plein de trucs à goûter
surtout j'ai même pas le temps mais je
le regrette je le regrette mais je passe
toujours sur le stand de la région Grand
Est passer sur le stand Corse c'est pas
mal c'est vrai ouais ouais je le ferai
question de quel pays la grande
distribution française est-elle la plus
dépendante en terme
d'approvisionnement c'est une très bonne
question donc très concrètement chez
nous pour par exemple la fabrication des
produits à 80 % c'est fabriqué par des
entreprises françaises donc le problème
est c'est réglé et les 20 % restant
c'est la charcuterie italienne des
produits grecs de la charcuterie
espagnole des choses comme ça donc déjà
sur nos 6000 produits à nous c'est très
franco-français après
euh il y a des dépendance avec de très
nombreux pays est-ce qu'on peut dire
qu'il y a un pays ben l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine il y avait une dépendance à
l'Ukraine qui était un espèce de grenier
à tournol à blé à production de verre
voilà les trois grands sujets que que
j'ai en tête là il y avait une vraie
dépendance c'est vrai il y en a-t-il une
autre avec un autre pays de ce type là
je crois pas la Russie avec les engrais
non le
gaz oui mais on a trouvé aujourd'hui
d'autres d'autres
approvisionnements
voilà on cherchait tout à l'heure on a
eu un trou de mémoire simultanée sur la
FAO en français organisation des Nations
Unies pour l'aliment
VO et l'agriculture et par contre je je
tout à fait c'est ça et je confirme que
c'était bien ma source était bien une
source
FAO alors question question compliquée
ou pas compliquée du tout à répondre
comment Monsieur
chelcher justifie-t-il que des patrons
de magasin soient presque tous
millionnaires tandis que les employés se
noit dans une précarité
terrible vue de l'esprit je me reconnais
pas dans ce dans ce
descriptif chez u moi je prends
l'exemple de U peut-être que c'est le
notre auditeur ou notre téléspectateur
pense à internaut ou internaut pense
à un autre exemple nous on est des
patrons de
PME je veux dire c'est en moyenne plutôt
des supermarchés on a que 60
hypermarchés
euh donc c'est plutôt des des des des
PME c'est aller entre 50 et 100 100
collaborateurs en en moyenne je veux
dire on on on travaille et on vit dans
des ambiances familiales
euh on cherche à être le plus exemplaire
possible dans sa gestion sociale sinon
ça ne marche pas voilà voilà le modèle
de base que j'ai qu'il y ait des
exceptions et des mauvais exemples
peut-être mais ils ne sont pas les plus
représentatifs de notre
métier question internet projection
expérience de pensée hiver 2025 les bas
deelain ont fini de fondre l'hiver est
froid et les coups de l'énergie ont
encore explosé entre les mal logés et
les mal nourris les mécontents ont
atteint la masse critique et les pièages
de supermarché se multiplient comment
réagitil a-t-il déjà un scénario de
gestion de
crise
c'est une excellente question
euh on a toujours on a toujours comment
dire été attentif euh comment dire à ce
qui a pu se passer à l'étranger pour
voir pour voir ce qui a pu se passer à
l'étranger et cetera au aujourd'hui je
n'ose pas imaginer un un un tel un tel
scénario en France mais j'ai bien
observé que pendant euh la crise qu'on a
décrite tout à l'heure au mois de juin
il y a effectivement eu euh dans
certains zones d'épillag y compris
alimentaires donc euh surtout
alimentaire surtout alimentaire assive
de la crème hydratante absolument à à ce
moment-là pour moi c'est le scénario du
pire et donc euh c'est le scénario du
pire et il faudra tout faire pour ne pas
en arriver là et et donc moi à mon
modeste niveau je me bas pour essayer de
de de de de bon déjà que que notre
chaîne accompagne les Français du mieux
qu'elle peut et pour faire bouger des
lignes pour permettre un contexte qui
qui qui qui permette au au au maximum de
gens de s'en sortir et pour moi le
scénario déécrit là est le scénario du
pire il faut évidemment se battre pour
l'éviter à tout prix et ne pas en
arriver là c'est pas possible en France
au 21e
siècle il a il y a combien de personnes
qui mangent pas à leur fa là 16 % je
disais que c'est 16 % de Français qui ne
mangent pas leur faim question
internet je suis producteur fermier
comment explique-t-il l'augmentation des
marges dans ces grandes surfaces sur mes
produits passant de 40 à 60 %. alors
après je sais pas si ces chiffres sont
bons il ils font le même chiffre mais
pas
moi je reviens à mon explication de
péréquation des marges que j'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure sur certains produits
nous prenons très peu de marge sur
d'autres produits nous prenons plus de
marge
l'équilibre global de cette péréquation
nous conduit à un résultat de 2 % de
résultat net pas plus et même moins
d'après le dernier la dernière étude
linéaire que je décrivais tout à l'heure
voilà après j'ai pas le cas précis de ce
producteur là qui n'hésite pas à revoir
le magasin qui vend le produit à ce prix
là qu' rediscute de la marge mais au
bout de cette péréquation ce n'est que
pour de pour de résultats net
et et encore une fois c'est bien moins
que dans toutes les industries
particulièrement dans les industries
agroalimentaire ce n'est pas chez nous
qu'il y a la plus grande part de valeur
finale question question
internet la loi égalim de 2018 prévoit
d'encadrer en valeur et en volume les
opérations promotionnelles le
consommateur sera perdant en temps de
crise et d'inflation comment pensez-vous
que les consommateurs vont
réagir bien sûr la la égalim 2 nous
obligeait à limiter la promotion à 34 %
sur l'alimentaire pour protéger le
revenu aussi du monde agricole c'était
une question précédente comment éviter
la course au prix bas la loi égalim 3 va
limiter à partir du 1er mars prochain
les
promotions les promotions sur la partie
droguerie parfumerie hygienne à 34 %
également alors qu'actuellement sur des
couches sur sur des lessifes sur des
shampoings on peut faire jusqu'à 60 70 %
de promo d'ailleurs comme cette
disposition se termine dans quelques
jours il y a des promotions
extraordinaires en ce moment même dans
tous les magasins chez nous et chez les
autres et donc ce que je dis c'est que
cette loi qui arrive au premier en
fonction au 1er mars arrive au plus
mauvais moment je suis d'accord on
s'était battu contre on n pas eu gain de
cause et et ça arrive au mauvais moment
dans ce contte contexte inflationniste
mais là c'est pas nous qui sommes en
cause c'est les élus qui ont choisi de
mettre en œuvre cette
loi question Internet pendant que je
récupère autre
chose vous négociez avec les petits
producteurs aussi c'est ça vousut
négocier leurs tarif les petits
producteurs en France il y a une loi qui
dit que quel que soit le producteur avec
qui vous travailler vous devez avoir un
contrat qu'il soit très grand ou qu'il
soit très petit donc même il sont petit
vous les aideer
prenez en moins de marge mais bien sûr
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure le petit producteur on accepte
son prix de vente tel tel qu'il est il y
a pas de discussion que question
internet que pensent-il des impacts
écologiques des grandes distributions
n'a-t-il pas mieux à faire n'y a-t-il
pas mieux à faire pardon n'y a-t-il pas
mieux à faire pour relocaliser la
production que pensent-il des
coopératives de
consommateurs nous sommes en chemin sur
notre transition environnementale bien
évidemment on peut faire beaucoup mieux
mais on a déjà fait de de très très
nombreux efforts sur le gaspiage
alimentaire sur les économies d'eau les
économies de consommation d'énergie dans
notre dans notre métier je vous donne un
chiffre très précis que je viens d'avoir
l'année dernière sous le coût de
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie on
a baissé notre consommation de 10 %
l'année dernière ère pour trouver euh
des des des façons de trouver des
économies face à
l'augmentation euh on met des du
photovoltaïque sur nos sur nos toitures
ou sur nos parkings c'est c'est en plus
maintenant une obligation mais on le
fait bien volontier parce que c'est bon
pour la planète bon pour la facture
d'énergie du magasin donc on donc on est
en chemin sur les sociétés coopérative
de consommateurs ben voilà il y a de
tout sur le le le marché euh c'est une
façon de se mettre ensemble pour trouver
des solutions maintenant est-ce que ça
peut être une solution à très très
grande échelle non je veux dire la
grande distribution
elle elle est là pour comment dire
servir et satisfaire un nombre très
important de clients sur un grand nombre
de produits bon quelle est la solution
au rapport qualité prix plus économique
c'est pas facile quoi à grande échelle
les 1 lites de lait vous les achetez com
sur euh le contrat que j'ai signé tout à
l'heure pour le lait bio on était à plus
de 500 € les 1000 litres
d'accord dans ça c'était pour du lait
bio c'était pour du lait bio pour euh
dans Dans les dernières négociations qui
viennent de s'achever parmi les premiers
contrats qu'on a signé c'était des
contrats de producteur laitiers par
exemple la coopérative Laita la
coopérative pardon entre
mon SODIAL Lactalis c'est qui le patron
alors Lactalis ça va être discuté
maintenant par ça c'est les grandes
entreprises c'est pour le 31
janvier et on a signé sur ces
producteurs de l'El là encore un peu en
hausse pour justement qu'il y ait une
juste rémunération des des producteurs
on a très rapidement trouvé un accord
qui était constructif maintenant voilà
je peux pas dire le chiffre précis c'est
le secret des affaires mais c'était en
Haus il y aura pas il y aura pas de
baisse de prix sur ces produits là pour
qu'il a un juste prix pour le producteur
donc le lait est très sensible chez nous
on y fait très attention mais je dis une
chose nous on paye un prix à un
producteur et c'est ce producteur qui
lui va rémunérer l'agriculteur au final
moi je paye pas directement
l'agriculteur et donc la question du
prix payé moi je paye un prix mais que
paye l'industriel ça je ne le maîtrise
pas et ça souvent on l'oublie c'est le
secret des affaires
oui il y a une partie aussi de secret
des affaires mais même moi quand je
paye l'idéal dans ce monde serait que le
prix que je paye à l'industriel je je
sache le prix qu'il paye à l'agriculteur
et ça on n pas toujours la transparence
on n pas toujours la transparence alors
il y a une question qui a été posée par
notre
francocadien sur les statistiques de vol
verronsnous des steaks S comme salbury
Londres on a déjà
parlé double question pour Monsieur
chelcher quelle est la part du chiffre
d'affaires de Système U qui est versé en
dividende aux actionnaires première
question quels sont les facteurs qui
peuvent expliquer que Système U ne
propose pas des prix sensiblement
inférieurs à des groupes comme Carrefour
Lecler dont la part de dividende est
énormes et en augmentation que que la
que les prix sont quoi je répète la
question quels sont les facteurs qui
peuvent expliquer que Système U ne
propose pas des prix sensiblement
inférieurs à des groupes comme Carrefour
Leclerc dont la part des dividendes est
énorme et en augmentation point
interrogation Système U est le deuxième
acteur du marché en terme de prix c'est
pas moi qui le dis c'est les études
externes hyperu est juste derrière le
CLER en terme de positionnement prix et
SuperU est le supermarché généraliste le
moins cher de France aujourd'hui dans
les études par exemple les fact checker
peuvent aller vérifier ça se trouve sur
internet sur les réseaux sociaux les
tableaux de comparatif de prix du
journaliste s'appelle Olivier Davert
traduisent l'échelle de prix et ben u
n'a pas à rougir de ses prix et ultra
compétitif actuellement et donc sur la
question des dividendes il y a pas de
grand actionnaire de à à payer chez
systèmeu puisque nous sommes une
confédération de PME une coopérative de
PME c'est le résultat est fait au niveau
de chaque magasin à hauteur de 2 % du
résultat et ça reste au niveau du
magasin qui va réinvestir qui va
agrandir qui va acheter des panneaux
photovoltaïques mais on ne paye pas
d'actionnaire extérieur chez nous avec
son suivi tick est toujours question
internet avec son suivi ticket d'après
lui le français moyen se nourritil
bien difficile à dire ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que est-ce qu'il y a une
augmentation des alcools et euh de la
junk food la confort fou de ce qu'on
appelle la la nourriture qui vous
réconforte moi je ne l'appelle pas comme
ça je l'appelle la nourriture plaisir
pour la première fois depuis la crise
covid en
2023 la nourriture plaisir a de nouveau
un peu progressé c'est-à-dire que malgré
les difficultés c'est quoi la nourriture
plaisir un exemple c'est le chocolat les
gâteaux les bonbons
euh certaines boissons
lesquelles j'ai pas en tête
le détail ça j'ai j'ai la courbe par par
contre en tête ça légèrement progressé
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que bien
que les temps soient difficiles il faut
trouver des petites madeleines de prou
il faut se faire des petits plaisirs et
et et et plaisir au sucre au sucre voilà
mais
l'alimentation et le rapport à
l'alimentation reste important chez les
Français donc il y a cette notion de de
de plaisir après pour répondre à
l'analyse du ticket et observe-t-on
quelque chose on peut dire que dans dans
parmi les les gens les plus modestes
quand on quand on observe en détail il y
a parfois plus de produits transformés
que dans d'autres cadis et donc de la
junk food je vous prends un
exemple au lieu d'acheter une baguette
une plaquette de beurre du jambon pour
faire un sandwich et cetera on on a
facilement dans dans un certain nombre
de paniers des produits transformés tout
fait mais qui coûtent plus cher
individuellement alors que s'ils étaient
préparés euh à l'ancienne ça coûterait
un peu moins cher et donc et avec moins
d'emballage peut-être en plus avec moins
d'emballage donc il y a un vrai sujet
mais là on peut en parler 5 minutes on
peut en parler 5 minutes il y a un
problème de de de de culture euh et de
formation à l'alimentation en France ça
ne fait plus partie de l'éducation on se
bat chez eu avec un groupe pour refaire
revenir l'éducation à l'alimentation à
l'école il y a quelques temps
euh mon équipe vous préférez pas le
théâtre pourquoi du théâtre à la rentrée
plutôt que des cours de cuisine ah non
non non les cours de cuisine sont pour
moi beaucoup plus importants je je je
vous explique on avait un stand sur un
salon agricole euh quelque part en
France et sur ce stand on avait des
animations et une des animations
c'était pour les jeunes reconnaisser les
fruits et les et les légumes c'était une
catastrophe c'était une catastrophe un
jeune français reconnaît encore une
patate parfois une carotte mais le reste
un Panet par exemple il ne sait plus ce
que c'est c'était dramatique premier
exemple deuxième exemple j'étais il y a
quelques temps avec le président de la
Banque Alimentaire le précédent comment
il s'appelle euh là tout de suite son
nom M parce qu'il y en a eu un nouveau
depuis mais j'étais dans son bureau on
discute de choses et d'autres il me dit
euh Dominique il y a quelques temps dans
un de nos centres en région parisienne
j'avais reçu une palette de
chou-fleur on na pas réussi à écouler
cette palette de chou-fleur au don au au
bénéficiaair pourquoi parce que il ne
savaiit pas comment le cuisiner une
palette de magnifiques chou-fleurs frais
les gens disaient non non je veux pas ça
je sais pas comment le cuisiner voilà où
on en est aujourd'hui donc il y a une
urgence de l'éducation à l'alimentation
il y a une urgence de de de réexpliquer
que d'acheter une petite cotelette euh
un un un légume frais une pomme de terre
avec que tu transformes en purée et
cetera coûtera toujours moins cher et
fera plusieurs repas si tu mets en
barquette que tu réchauffes et cetera
que d'acheter le produit transformé mais
on est loin de ça aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus ces repèreslà et dans beaucoup de
familles on on et si c'est plus comment
dire à l'école dans beaucoup de familles
il y il y a plus comme dans le temps la
grand-mère qui apprenait à cuisiner et
cetera et ça c'est des choses de base
qui se sont perdu et qui contribuent
aussi peut-être à la gravité de la
situation actuelle vous
cuisinez peu moi personnellement c'est
Madame c'est passionnant non c'est c'est
c'est c'est ma femme qui cuisine
évidemment et elle cuisine d'illeurs
très bien non mais d'accord vous
cuisinez pas du tout non alors vous
savez pas cuisiner je je si alors c'est
qu'est-ce que vous savez cuisiner alors
qu'est-ce que je sais cuisiner déjà je
je je je cuisine des desserts pour mes
enfantsel c'est mon cake est sans doute
meilleur que celui de Cédric Grolet à
Paris je rigole mais je je je par
exemple ouais moi c'est des choses
simples
euh des des plats traditionnels une
bonne choucroû
fait la ch et cetera ben déjà c'est
d'acheter les bons produits et qu'elle
cuise longtemps ensemble dans une belle
terine
alsacienne et et tranquillement et
cetera
mais j'adore les produits j'adore les
produits et cetera je cuisine
peu je je prends pas ce temps-là je
prends pas ce tempsl est-ce que ça s'est
perdu à cause de l'offre industrielle de
comment ah pardon est-ce que ça s'est
plat préparé qui a explosé le fait qu'on
sache plus cuisiner ou est-ce que c'est
parce que il y a plus de
transmission intergénérationnelle non
pour moi c'est plus le sujet de la
transmission
intergénérationnelle
avant on se transmettait des recettes on
se transmettait des habitudes on on
travaillait les restes on ne jetait pas
et cetera aujourd'hui on a on a perdu
cette dimension là plus que voilà après
après du coup bah n'ayant plus ça on se
on se précipite sur des produits
transformés emballés et cetera mais mais
ça c'est la conséquence pour moi le
choufleur vous fait vous le faites vous
le cuisinez comment à l'eau
tranquillement le plus longtemps
possible je peux en faire aussi un
gratin après avec avec un peu de fromage
dessus gratiner au four pour finir par
exemple pané avec une petite chapelure
exactement pané avec une petite ch plure
ça c'est très ma grand-mère qui faisait
ça ou cru avec une petite maillot non CR
j'aime pas tellement cru pourquoi ça
fait péter je sais pas les chou de
Bruxelles vous les faites comment
euh bah pareil alors je suis moi F des
chous de Bruxelles mais si les chous de
Bruxelles non je préfère les brocolis je
préfère les brocolis vous avez commis un
livre que je viens juste de recevoir et
et je vais je vais être tout à fait
honnête je l'ai même pas ouvert ça
s'appelle comment ça s'appelle le
bonheur est dans le prê pas dans le prê
dans le prê et dans ce livre bah sorti
au print commce au cœur du vivre
ensemble c'est voilà je en fait je je
parle de tout ce dont on vient de parler
Domini
attrae j'aimerais que tu me choisisses
une page et que tu me lise un bout
alors
je suis vache le nez bouché la
sinusite les magasins U s'engagent aussi
sur la réduction du gaspillage vente de
produits à date courte confection de
paniier de fruits et légumes moches
partenariat avec des start-ups comme tog
to go qui un très gros partenaire de
Système U qui vise à transformer la
gestion des invendus en une action
positive sur le plan social
environnemental et économique enfin les
reliques cas du gaspillage sont placés
en méthanisation pour produire de
l'énergie et du chauffage ces boucles
vertueuses permettent de réduire
l'impact de la consommation sur la
planète c'est exactement ce que je vous
ai dit au hasard et donc je ce livre en
fait RET enfin parle beaucoup de tout ce
dont on a parlé ce soir question
internet qui est peut-être une fausse
assertion
d'ailleurs quand est-ce que vous arrêtez
de mettre des surmarges sur les produits
bio
il y a un vrai sujet des produits bio
actuellement effectivement qui sont en
en
panne de vente pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont sensiblement plus chers que que les
autres et et ben en période d'inflation
ils sont ils sont un peu boudés il y a
une enquête d'un d'une revue de
consommateur qui est un peu caricaturé
et et et je crois que ce mot surmarge
était présent dans dans cette enquête
qui a caricat
comment dire la vente le le les marches
sur un certain nombre de fruits et
légumes frais on avait détaillé ça et et
regarder en détail non il y a pas de
surmarche sur les fruits et légumes
frais bio plus que d'autres et cetera
parce que de toute façon sinon on on on
les vend pas donc je m'inscris en faux
contre l'étude qui avait diffusé cette
idéelà le bio ça coûte un peu plus cher
à produire parce que ben il y a un plus
respectueux de l'environnement et cetera
et c'est ça à la base qui fait que les
produits sont un peu plus chers c'est
pas nos marges qui rendent les produits
plus chers c'est le fait que la
production est de meilleure qualité
coûte un peu plus cher alors là il y a
c'est pas une question c'est un
commentaire et c'est dans la partie qui
est dans la question d'habitude on
bannit à grand coup de pied dans les
fesses ce type de commentaire parce que
ce n'est pas dans la bonne rubrique mais
on va faire un une
exception c'est c'est un commentaire qui
est
dur il va falloir peut-être y répondre
mais c'est à vous de choisir le
commentaire c'est encore un lâche qui
donne des bonnes manières des bonnes
leçons mais qui n'ose même pas donner
son
salaire un un lâche qui n'ose pas donner
son salaire je ne vois pas ce que donner
mon salaire apporte au débat je répète
j'ai un salaire de cadre supérieur j'ai
pas un salaire de grand patron du 440 du
tout euh voilà et vous croyez en
Dieu
ah je m'attendais pas du tout à cette
question bah c'est fait
exprès je crois en quelque chose qui
nous
dépasse question internet bonsoir u
achète-t-il des terrains agricoles afin
de maximiser ses profits
des terrains agricoles pour maximiser
ses profits ben
non je vois pas vous savez de toute
façon
acheter artificialisé du sol devient de
plus en plus compliqué en France et on
ne s'en plaint pas du tout je comprends
le débat et cetera donc agrandir nos
magasins créer de nouveaux magasins
c'est extrêmement difficile mais on
nachète pas des terrains pour pour
artificialiser plus qu'il il ne faut
tout ça est très normé très strict
question Internet où fait-il ses achats
alimentaires pour lui-même bah dans mon
magasin bien évidemment à prix coûtant
ou vous payez ah je paye le prix je paye
je alors je fais mes courses je vais
vous dire c'est le vendredi soir et je
passe en caisse comme tout le monde bien
évidemment hein et je paye le prix
normal et comme vous cuisinez pas c'est
forcément votre femme qui vous fait la
liste de courses c'est ça elle me fait
la liste de courses elle fait aussi des
courses de son de de de de son côté elle
me fait la petite liste complémentaire
et non non mais bien sûr que
pensent-t-il des accords de libre
échange comme celui avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui entre en vigueur
début 2024 il prévoit une quasi
élimination des droits de douane sur les
Kiwii les oignons les pommes les
poissons le vin le miel ainsi que le
fromage le lait la viande en provenance
de Nouvelle-Zélande je je ne suis pas un
spécialiste des des accords de ce type
là mais ce que je dis c'est bien sûr que
euh on ne peut pas venir concurrencer
des productions françaises avec des
produits d'importation
produit à à des
conditions de qualité moindre avec des
normes moindres et qui viendrait
injustement concurrencer la production
française ça c'est pas possible ça c'est
pas possible donc donc je suis d'accord
avec les agriculteurs sur ce plan là je
dire faut faire attention à à la
concurrence je dirais
injuste qui viendrait prendre sur leur
territoire voilà ringis on en a pas
parlé de ringis alors attention je vous
ai dit notre siège est à ringis mais il
n'est pas au sein du marché de ringis il
est dans le parc d'activité qui est
juste en face donc je ne suis pas au
cœur du marché deingis vous déjà été au
cœur du marché deingis oui j'ai fait la
visite j'ai vu la préparation de la tête
de veau à 3h du matin puisque c'est le
pass obligé quand on visite le marché de
il y a la grande fresque derrière c'est
ça
euh j'en ai pu le souvenir mais
probablement le steak frit à 7h du matin
à la fin de la visite oui bien sûr j'ai
connu ça je connais Stéphane Layani le
patron du marché actuel qui m'avait fait
le plaisir de faire la visite en
personne non non c'est c'est un un
endroit formidable
évidemment on va le faire venir je pense
ouais alors alors là il a beaucoup chos
à dire Stéphane est-ce que vous voyez un
sujet qu'on a pas
abordé il y a tellement de questions il
y a tellement de questions ah oui non
écoutez on a on a abordé énormément de
sujets à travers l'ensemble de de vos
questions y y a-t-il un
sujet particulier
ben voilà ils sont il sont ça interdit
ça c'est interdit ils sont dans le livre
ils sont dans le livre Les les les
autres sujets pour mieux connaître le
métier est-ce que vous pouvez est-ce que
vous pouvez recommander trois livres à
notre communauté trois livres à votre
communauté des livres qui ont été
marquants pour vous marquant pour moi
alors le premier
c'est mon livre essentiel ce sont les
Essais de
Montaigne
alors c'est pas le livre le plus lu par
c'est j'ai rencontré
Montaigne dans mon épreuve du bac j'ét
interrogé au bac là-dessus sur
l'accoutume à la mort et Montaigne ne
m'a plus jamais quitté depuis là j'ai lu
les essais en entier euh je le relis je
me replonge dedans régulièrement pour
moi c'est le premier philosophe
Montaigne est le premier philosophe des
temps modernes des temps modernes dans
son style à lui et il a lit deux choses
l'homme d'action il était mère de
Bordeaux il était mère pendant la peste
au au 17e siècle et c'était un homme de
réflexion qui a écrit ses essais pour
réfléchir sur lui et et sur l'intime et
cetera et j'aime ces deux notions et
pour moi c'est un livre fondateur
essentiel premier
livre deuxième livre et et et là il est
il est ressorti l'année dernière dans la
collection bouquin et vraiment je le
conseille je le conseille à tout le
monde un auteur qui s'appelle Jean-René
hugenin qui est un un auteur des années
60 qui malheureusement heureusement est
mort à l'âge de 26 ans et qui a écrit
deux choses qui a écrit tout d'abord un
un un roman magnifique qui s'appelle la
côte sauvage une histoire de famille
entre un frère et une sœur absolument
magnifique était plein plein de
promesses et un journal intime son
journal personnel et c'est surtout
celui-là qu'il faut lire et ce journal
est un journal fondateur pour tout jeune
qui se cherche puisqu'il est confronté
aux réflexions de cet auteur absolument
fabuleux qui est mort dans un accident
de la route à 26 ans et l'année dernière
dans la collection bouquin est sorti la
réunion de son œuvre donc le journal la
côte sauvage et de la correspondance et
c'est magnifique et et je et je regrette
tellement la mort de cet auteur et le
troisième livre ça faire une allusion
à à une passion je collectionne les
dictionnaires et donc euh en français ou
dans toutes les langues alors d'abord
les dictionnaires en alors en en langue
française d'abord c'était une passion
pour les dictionnaires consacrés à la
langue française et aujourd'hui je suis
dans les dictionnaires thématiques et
donc je mets en avant ce soir avec vous
particulement une collection séchz plomb
la collection des dictionnaires amoureux
il y en a 1660 que j'ai je les ai tous
bien évidemment euh et je et je parlerai
là particulièrement du Dictionnaire
amoureux des dictionnaires du coup mais
ils sont tous fabuleux le Dictionnaire
amoureux de l'Alsace le Dictionnaire
amoureux de Montaigne le Dictionnaire
amoureux de de de Gaul que j'ai dévoré
je lis beaucoup de biographie aussi et
cetera donc voilà les les trois livres
que que je citerai est-ce que vous avez
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
une bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur les
réseaux souvent on me demande mais
comment fait pour en arriver au plus
grandes responsabilités c'est souvent
une question que j'ai et ben aux jeunes
je dirais aujourd'hui vous savez il y a
plein de gens de de plein de de talent
d'un tal
immense intelligent et cetera la
différence souvent c'est la persévérance
et donc moi je dis aux
jeunes persévérrez persévérrez vous
aurez des échecs vous aurez des échecs
dépasser ces échec tirezen les les
leçons pour être meilleur la fois
d'après vous aurez des obstacles sur
votre chemin franchissez ces obstacles
ne vous arrêtez pas aux obstacles la
différence entre parfois des gens plein
de talent mais entre ceux qui vont
parfois plus loin c'est la persévérance
et donc je dis mon plus grand message et
celui aussi peut-être que je je veux
repasser à mes enfants finalement c'est
persévérer et vous irez loin chque BR
disait exactement la même chose
Dominique chelcher merci merci à vous
merci
beaucoup
[Musique]